bonjour et bienvenue pour ce sixième
épisode 7/6 leçon de paléo mammalogie ou
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de
l'évolution des homininés j'ai envie de
dire que dans une perspective africaine
de l'évolution des mammifères
il est à peu près impensable de ne pas
envisager de donner toute une leçon sur
l'évolution des hominidés puisque
l'évolution des hominidés est si
intimement liées géographiquement à
l'afrique
alors j'aime démarrer secours en
rappelant déjà ce que c'est l'évolution
parce qu'évidemment l'évolution humaine
c'est toujours un sujet plus épineux que
les autres donc l'évolution c'est quoi
et bien quand vous regardez cet arbre
finalement et bien vous pourriez vous
dire comment cet arbre a évolué ou
agrandis pour pouvoir enjamber ce trou
et je vous répondrai et bien que
l'évolution ce n'est pas comprendre
comment cet arbre à
agrandi pour enjamber se troue
l'évolution c'est de comprendre que par
le passé les choses étaient différentes
et qu'en l'occurrence le trou n'existait
pas donc le trou s'est formée après que
l'arbre et grandit donc c'est ça
vraiment l'évolution l'évolution c'est
comprendre que les choses n'évoluent pas
pour quelque chose que les choses
n'évoluent pas dans un but c'est
comprendre qu'en fait dans le passé
les conditions étaient différentes les
choses étaient différence et c'est pour
ça qu'on a besoin de la paléontologie
pour avoir ce regard direct vers le
passé parce que quelles que soient les
hypothèses que vous pouvez mettre en
vous basant sur des données modernes sur
des données anatomiques ou génétique
moderne et bien les fossiles ce sera
toujours des points de passage
obligatoire de votre théorie parce que
ce sont des points d'ancrage solide
voilà le les fossiles ce sont des
preuves directes de ce qu'était le passé
une autre chose que j'aime rappeler aux
débuts de secours puisque je donne cours
à des étudiants qui ceux qui vivent à
johannesbourg et bien c'est que
johannesbourg
c'est très connu pour être une ville où
la criminalité est très élevé et les
étudiants ont tendance à croire que
johannesbourg et internationalement
connu pour sa criminalité et bien en
fait j'aime bien leur rappeler que non
la plupart du temps quand les gens
entendent parler de johannesbourg en
dehors de l'afrique et notamment en
europe et en amérique ou bien encore au
japon comme on peut le voir ici ou en
russie eh bien ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
à propos de la sécurité ou de la
corruption ou de quoi que ce soit
c'est à propos des découvertes
d'hominidés fossiles voilà donc
johannesbourg c'est le coeur finalement
deux de la recherche en évolution des
hominidés tout simplement parce qu'à 50
km de là vous avez le ce que ce que
l'unesco appelle le berceau de
l'humanité je sais qu'à chaque fois on
me dit gnagnagna on doit pas utiliser le
mot berceau de l'humanité c'est le nom
du site jeu c'est le nom que l'unesco
donne au site le berceau de l'humanité
donc voilà il ya des centaines de
grottes là bas
seulement 18 ont été réellement explorer
donc il ya des tas de nouvelles
découvertes qui sont faites d'hominidés
là bas dans ce berceau de l'humanité
et voilà et c'est à seulement 50 km de
johannesbourg et c'est à johannesbourg
que les fossiles que qui sont
découvertes au berceau de l'humanité
sont étudiées et qu'ensuite ils sont
gardés donc dans la même université où
je fais court donc et ça je pense que
c'est important de le rappeler aussi
pour pour ce qui est de l'importance
finalement du patrimoine paléontologique
même du point de vue politique c'est à
dire que avoir un patrimoine
paléontologique et savoir le mettre en
avant
ça a un rayonnement international et ça
je pense que c'est important de le
rappeler
et pas seulement pour l'afrique du sud
ça peut être vrai pour tous les pays
pensez à l'amérique par exemple ils ont
un rayonnement international à chaque
fois qu'un qu'une nouvelle espèce de
tyrannosaures et découvert penser à la
chine où on entend parler d'eux à chaque
fois qu'ils ont à nouveau dinosaure à
plumes donc voilà ne pas avoir ne pas
mettre en avant son patrimoine
paléontologique ce n'est pas grave le
mettre en avant
ça peut vous donner une image à
l'international qui est très différente
de l'image que vous croyez données en
réalité voilà
et puis j'ai envie de rappeler aussi que
l'évolution humaine elle n'est pas aussi
simple que certaines représentations
veulent bien le prétendre donc cette
représentation elle a au moins
l'avantagé de
de représenter des mâles et des femelles
et pas seulement des mâles mais bon au
final on commence quand même pas des
petits noirs et on finit quand même par
des grands blancs donc voilà je sais
c'est une image tu vas falloir on va
essayer d'évacuer sahin comme image
pendant ce court
on a des représentations qui sont un peu
plus correct j'aime bien cette
représentation parce qu'elle est très
stylisé elle est très jolie et elle ne
fait elle ne représente finalement que
dès que du crâne que du squelette quoi
donc il ya que du fossile là dedans
donc elle me plait pas mal cette image
oui mais je veux dire vous avez quand
même une branche qui démarre ici et qui
termine là donc qui part en arrière il y
à une branche de cet arbre qui part en
arrière
d'ailleurs il y en a pas qu'une en
réalité il y en a encore une la bref
donc des arbres phylogénétiques avec des
branches qui parents qui partent en
arrière la réponse est non
et puis vous avez des choses comme ça
qui traînent dans la littérature oui
madame
oui monsieur vous avez des choses comme
ça avec donc un ancêtre commun ici la
lignée qui mène aux chimpanzés bonobos
on peut être d'accord mais alors vous
avez ça veut dire ça c'est une
représentation de la phylogénie des
hominidés qu'on trouve dans la
littérature c'est je les ai pas inventés
celle là c'est de la folie pure et dure
avec des ronds points des ronds-points
évolutif des demi-tours évolutif dd non
non non non what the fuck exactement
what the fuck
donc voilà on va essayer de remettre un
peu tout ça en ordre pendant ce court et
on va commencer par la diapo à laquelle
je m'étais à haut niveau de laquelle je
m'étais arrêté la dernière fois donc si
vous n'avez pas vu le cours sur les
primates jouglar fait rapidement qu'est
ce qui caractérise les homininés donc
les homininés
du clad au mini ni qu'on appelle aussi
des hominidés de façon commune a comme
je les dis le le terme commun pour
parler des eaux minini ça devrait être
aux minimes mais ça sonne vraiment très
anglais donc généralement on dit
hominidés ou homininés en français voilà
donc ce clad apparaît à la fin du
miocène avec ça elle entre aux puces et
donc ça elle entre aux puces a déjà tous
les traits du d'homininés moderne à
savoir la bipédie comme indiqué par la
position ventrale du foramen magnum qui
va de pair avec une colonne vertébrale
verticale sous le corps comme chez les
australopithèques et les humains et non
pas horizontale ils ont et sahel entre
opus à une usure des canines des îles à
des petites canine et une usure des
canines qui indique que les canines du
dessus passé à l'avant des canines du
dessous alors que chez un chimpanzé ou
un gorille comme vous voyez là c'est les
canines du dessous qui part qui passe
devant les canines du dessus donc les
canines du dessous à l'avant des canines
du dessus c'est un caractère primitif et
nous on ne l'a pas nous on a les canines
du dessus qui passe à l'avant des
canines du dessous et ça ça va de pair
avec une réunion une réduction du
progrès at his mais c'est à dire de la
projection de la mâchoire vers l'avant
donc voilà pour les caractères qui
définissent les eaux minini mais il y en
a évidemment beaucoup d'autres notamment
ceux qui sont liés à la posture
donc comme je les dis il ya la posture
bipèdes chez les ch et les eaux minines
qui est très importante et donc on
compare en comparant à un chimpanzé donc
à un quadrupède
eh bien on constate que les quadrupèdes
n'ont qu'une seule courbe finalement
dans leurs colonnes vertébrales alors
que nous on en a une
2 3 et 4 donc pourquoi cas très bien
parce que si vous redresser en fait ceci
vous allez finir avec un corps
effectivement verticale mais la tête va
pointer vers le haut donc vous avez
besoin d'une première courbure pour
ramener la tête vers l'avant puis vous
allez avoir besoin d'une autre courbure
parce que si évidemment si vous juste
vous redresser sa à la verticale vous
allez avoir les pieds qui vont pointer
vers l'avant russie bah oui donc il vous
faut une deuxième courbure pauvres pour
ramener les pieds en dessous et c'est
comme ça que vous finissez avec des tas
de courbure dans votre colonne verte
voilà vous partez de une courbure vous
la mettez à la verticale il vous faut
une nouvelle courbure pour mettre la
tête en avant et vous faut une nouvelle
courbure pour amener les pieds au sol
vous allez avoir aussi des variations au
niveau de la longueur des membres donc
évidemment les les grands singes est en
primitivement bras qui a tort c'est à
dire qui se balade avec les bras ils se
baladent suspendu par les bras eh bien
ils ont des bras qui sont plus longs que
les jambes alors que chez les humains
on a les bras qui sont plus courts que
les jambes les jambes sont plus longues
ce qui est une adaptation à la marche
mais aussi à la course et puis vous avez
aussi la forme du bassin donc la forme
du bassin chez les êtres humains le
bassin est plus large que l'on alors que
chez les grands singes le bassin est
plus long que large
est-ce qu'il va de pair aussi avec la
position des fémurs chez les chez les
humains les fémurs forme un angle
rentrant ce qui permet en fait d'avoir
les genoux qui sont alignés avec le
poids du corps donc ce qui permet un
meilleur une meilleure distribution de
la charge alors que chez les grands
singes vous avez les fémurs qui sont
parallèles au poids du corps parce que
toute façon la charge est distribuée
entre les quatre membres et non pas sur
deux membres uniquement
et enfin au niveau des phalanges donc
des mains et des pieds aussi on va avoir
déjà la disparition du pouce préhensile
sur le pied donc le pied dès le pied des
grands singes à un pouce opposable ce
qu'on ne retrouve pas chez l'humain et
vous pouvez voir que ce pouce opposable
est relativement petit par rapport aux
autres doigts alors que le gros orteil
est le plus gros des orteils chez les
chez les humains donc ça c'est pareil
ces adaptations distribution de la
charge en fait vous vous rappelez donc
que chez les persos dactyle et les a
reçus à l'acte il on a une réduction du
nombre de doigts avec un ou deux doigts
majoritaire qui
qui encaisse la charge est bien chez les
humains c'est pareil c'est le gros
orteil qui fait office de doit porter de
charges
voilà avec le deuxième orteil de façon
moindre et c'est pour ça que souvent on
entend dire que le petit orteil est
entre guillemets condamné à disparaître
bon évidemment c'est c'est sans compter
une fête que nos jeunes expriment
exprimeront le petit orteil même s'il
n'est pas même s'il n'est pas activement
utile on va dire mais ceci étant dit il
est possible que effectivement si le si
la lignée humaine persiste encore
quelques millions d'années il est
possible qu'on finisse avec avec
justement à splint bonne comme celle et
comme chez les hommes comme chez les
persos dactyle où on a un petit réside
une métacarpe sur le côté c'est pas
impossible mais évidemment c'est la
spéculation on ne sait pas de quoi
l'évolution sera fait dans le futur donc
il y à déjà ça et il y à un haut niveau
des phalanges des mains donc vu que les
grands singes son bras catr ils ont des
phalanges courbet donc courbure que vous
voulez bien voir avec la comparaison
avec cette ligne horizontale
alors que chez homo sapiens les
phalanges sont beaucoup plus droite sur
les mains et aussi on a la taille des
doigts donc sur un grand sage les doigts
de la main
enfin les doigts de l'index jusqu à
l'auriculaire sont relativement grand
comparé au pouce qui est tout petit et
ça c'est encore une fois une adaptation
al abrach à sion pour la brakina sion
vous n'avez pas besoin d'attraper les
branches avec vos cinq doivent vous avez
juste besoin de vous suspendre avec vos
quatre grands avec vos quatre doigts
disto on va dire mais quand vous voulez
attraper et notamment de quand vous
voulez une
une attrape de précisions
vous avez besoin justement d'une main
avec un pouce opposable
mais un pouce opposable qui est aussi
grand que les autres doit donc voilà la
main alors tout à l'heure j'ai pris ça
comme exemple de pied mais évidemment le
pied fa le comment dire ça c'est bien à
pied pardon mais voilà ça ressemble à
une main donc ça ressemble à une main
humaine donc je vais utiliser ça comme
exemple de ma humaine voilà le pour
attraper avec précision vous avez besoin
d'un l'on doit d'un long pouce opposable
qui est presque aussi long que les
doigts les autres doit en fait donc ça
même si ça c'est un pied finalement ça
ressemble pas mal à une main humaine
parce que le pouce est très long par
rapport aux autres doigts
voilà donc comme je le disais ça elle
entre aux puces ce serait le plus ancien
hominidé connu donc entre 7 et 6
millions d'années donc fin du miocène
c'est ce serait même un des seuls
avec ardipithecus ce serait un des seul
nominé de du miocène donc 6 millions
d'années six à sept millions d'années et
alors comme je le disais la position
ventrale du foramen magnum et la l'usure
des canines donc l'usure apicale et non
pas frontale antérieures des canines
semble indiquer donc que cette qu'il
s'agit bel et bien d'un dan homininés
est en fait la petite taille des canines
a été parfois décrite comme étant le
résultat du fait que toumaï est une
femelle et non pas un mal et donc et
pour certains il s'agirait d'une femelle
soit gorille enfin de la lignée des
gorilles soit de la lignée des
chimpanzés
mais mais mais il y a le bourrelet sus
orbitaire le boulet sus orbitaire de
toumaï est gigantesque si ce qui pointe
quand même plutôt vers un mal plutôt
qu'une femelle
donc si on a un mal avec des petites
canine ça veut dire qu'on est face à
anne homininés le seul clad de dominos
id donc de grands singes chez qui les
mâles ont des petites canine
c'est les homininés donc voilà 2
voilà où en est le débat à l'heure
actuelle eu le est ce qu'il faut
préciser donc que toumaï démarre avec un
cerveau d'à peu près 400 centimètres
cubes donc un cerveau de 400 centimètres
cube c'est à peu près la capacité
crânienne
enfin une boîte crânienne pardon le
cerveau on l'a pas mais on a la boîte
crânienne et on part du principe que
c'est un reflet décemment précis du
cerveau donc la boîte crânienne fait 400
centimètres cubes et c'est ce qu'on
retrouve chez le chimpanzé le gorille
donc c'est l'état primitif on va dire
donc toumaï nous donne l'état primitif
de la taille de la boîte crânienne on va
voir que l'évolution de la boîte
crânienne aura son importance
évidemment celle est dans la lignée
humaine donc les l'autre l'autre
primates du mit en scène un autre
primate du miocène supérieur c'est aussi
horohorine donc qui vient du kenya 2 6
millions d'années a oui quelque chose
que je n'ai pas a précisé à propos de
toumaï c'est que toumaï contrairement à
tous ses cousins
il a été trouvé enfin tous ses cousins
sauf ardipithecus sauf australopithèques
us balles réelles gaz bar el ghazi par
lombard el ghazali toumaï toumaï a été
trouvé à l'ouest de l'afrique
et donc c'est le premier à mettre en
question la fameuse east side story de
yves coppens donc l'histoire de l'est de
l'afrique parce que tous les hominidés à
fond avant tout maille et
australopithecus babar el ghazali donc
abel un peu appelons le abel ce sera
plus simple pour tout le monde donc
avant ces deux là en gros tous les hôtes
ou les homininés fossiles ou presque
d'afrique avaient été retrouvés dans
cette diagonale qui se trouve à l'est de
l'afrique
donc qui aligne la vallée de la fare la
vallée de l'omo et le
et le cradle of humankind en afrique du
sud donc ce cette diagonale finalement
c'était c'était ce qu'on pourrait
appeler le berceau de l'humanité quoi et
donc maintenant on a tous mallet
australopithecus enfin abel donc qui
viennent de l'ouest de l'afrique du
tchad et qui du coup semble indiquer que
non c'est pas si simple
en fait c'est pas si simple et notamment
il y avait des scénarios comme quoi
l'affaissement en fait de cette vallée
de la vallée du rift con comme on
l'appelle aussi donc l'affaissement de
la vallée du rift et la réunification à
l'intérieur de la vallée du rift avait
poussé les hominidés à arrêter de vivre
dans les arbres et a commencé à marcher
debout dans les savanes
bon ben si to my sea to my vient
effectivement de loin de l'ouest
africain et ben ils vivaient dans la
forêt et l'environnement le
paléoenvironnement tel que reconstitué
indique bien un environnement forestier
donc on aurait la bipédie qui aurait
évolué en environnement forestier
hashtag je vous rappelle la la bipédie
arboricole donc bon on est sur du on est
sûr de la grosse incertitude 1 de ce
point de vue là et ont tout ce que je
peux tout ce qu'on peut dire à ce niveau
là c'est que il y avait il y avait liste
side story
maintenant il ya to my et l'italie liste
side story a du coup pris un peu de
plomb dans l aile quoi donc
or or in donc là cette fois on retourne
au kenya donc on revient du côté de la
vallée du rift revient à l'est de
l'afrique dont corinne il est surtout
connu par un fémur et quelques dents et
ce fémur il a la tête qui est bien
différencier du reste du corps du fémur
avec une tête bien rondes et non pas
ovale et donc ça c'est un caractère
qu'on retrouve chez les humains et pas
chez les grands singes
on constate aussi qu'à ce niveau là il
manque un petit à petit crochet au ce
crochet au ce qui est très développée
chez les chimpanzés et qui est beaucoup
plus réduit chez les humains bon encore
qu'évidemment il est pété donc ça aide
pas non plus bon et la distribution
aussi la densité osseuse à l'intérieur
de la tête
en fait semble indiquer une répartition
des charges
sur le fémur donc une des contraintes de
duos charge du corps sur le fémur
cohérente avec a avec une bipédie avec
la bipédie bon après voilà c'est des
grosses références fait sur du fémur
donc bon ça a surtout c'est surtout son
en parts en importance parce que comme
ça elle entre aux puces sahel entre opus
a été découvert par des paléontologues
français de poitiers
or au riz n'a été trouvée aussi par des
paléontologues français mais cette fois
du muséum d'histoire naturelle donc ça a
son importance pour nous parce que bas
parce que c'est cocorico quoi
ardipithecus bon là ça a été découvert
par de l'américain mais ardipithecus ils
sont intéressants il ya deux espèces
d'ardipithecus ils sont intéressants les
ardipithecus parce que déjà ils datent
de 5 millions d'années donc scellé les
plus récents des ce sont les plus
récents des hominidés du milieu scène on
va dire voilà donc les hominidés de la
toute fin du miocène et ardipithecus il
et il est très intéressant parce que
déjà on a un peu plus de matos on a on a
dû crânien on a des dents on a un peu de
colonne vertébrale un peu de bassins et
on a des membres
bon alors tout ça c'est du composite
évidemment c'est pas tous le même
individu
mais quand même ça permet de faire
quelques remarques assez intéressante
donc déjà on sait qu'il avait une petite
boîte crânienne une taille de cerveau
estimé à 400 centimètres cubes
on sait qu'il avait des petites canine
donc vous pouvez voir ici on sait qu'il
avait les donc ça c'est plutôt un
caractère d'hominidés vous pouvez voir
aussi voilà la petite canine ici avec
l'usure tenait très net ici l'usure
apicale donc au lieu d'avoir l'usure à
l'avant claque
ici on à l'usure qui est à l'arrière ici
dans ce qu'on appelle l'usure apicale
comme chez les humains
donc ça c'est pour et comme chez les
humains
vous avez le radius et le tibia donc l'
os de l'avant-bras et l'os de l'avant
jambes
du coup
qui sont à peu près de même taille alors
que chez les chimpanzés le radius donc
l' os de l'avant-bras est définitivement
plus grand essai par contre chez les
humains le fémur est définitivement plus
grand que le radius pardon le tibia est
définitivement plus grand que la radio
ce qui indique que les jambes sont plus
longue donc là pour ça ardipithecus et
intermédiaire donc vous avez un
caractère dumas vous avez définitivement
un foramen magnum qui se trouve en
position ventrale donc une bipédie mai
et vous avez aussi donc un tibia qui est
réduit et de même taille que le radius
donc des membres qui sont à peu près de
la même taille quoi des membres avant et
arrière qui sont antérieurs et
postérieurs qui sont à peu près de la
même taille donc tout ça c'est des
caractères plus tôt dérivée de
ardipithecus et qui font de lui à
nominer un peu plus dérivés que que ne
peut l'être par exemple celle entre opus
de l'autre côté on a aussi des
caractères qui sont très primitif chez
ardipithecus et notamment et bien vous
voyez le ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure voilà donc chez les chimpanzés
vous avez de très longs doigts depuis
l'index et l'auriculaire et un pouce
très courts et cher dit pit et cus le
pouce est toujours très très court
comparé aux humains les chez les humains
le pousser beaucoup plus long et permet
justement de fermer le pouce et l'index
d'avoir une précise ce qu'on appelle la
poule et six jeunes grippe
c'est à dire la trappe précise voilà la
morphologie aussi du bassin le bassin
semble assez 3 du mois intermédiaire
entre la condition humaine et la
condition primates
donc au lieu d'avoir un bassin qui
serait très très long ou un bassin qui
serait très très large on va aller on a
un bassin qui serait un peu
intermédiaire
mais les membres sont définitivement des
membres d'une espèce arboricole avec un
pouce opposable sur le pied est un peu
un pouce très réduits sur les mains et
des doigts fortement brac yater donc
donc on a vraiment avec ardipithecus on
a vraiment le premier assemblage la
première mosaïque de caractère à la fois
primitif et dérivés vraiment
identifiable sur un âne hominidé dont on
connaît quand même décemment le
squelette
ce qui nous amène au pliocène et au
début du pléistocène avec les fameuses
australopithèques signer donc les
australopithèques siné dont les membres
plus connus sont évidemment les
australopithèques us donc ce qu'il ya de
maintenant avec australopithèques us ce
qui est bien c'est qu'on a beaucoup
d'espèces différentes et que ces espèces
différentes donc nous deux nous ont
livré du beau matériel et notamment de
tout récemment on a little foot donc
little foot dont le squelette complet a
été révélée au public l'année dernière
en 2018 donc little foot il date de 3,7
millions d'années donc il est cinq cent
mille ans plus vieux que l'uci et le
squelette est complet à 90 % donc vous
pouvez donc le squelette est tout entier
chez little foot il manque justement que
quelques fragments du pied des fragments
du pied qui ont été découverts à la
dynamite donc si on n'avait pas
dynamiter le pied de little foot on
l'aurait peut-être pas trouvé du tout
mais si on l'avait pas dynamité on
aurait peut-être encore le pied voilà
mais bon c'est ça date des années 50
à l'époque il savait pas trop voilà donc
lidl foot ouais vous pouvez voir son la
main de little foot ici et vous voyez la
main et tout articulé ces magnifiques
vous voyez les doigts ici repliés sur
eux mêmes le pouce replié dans
l'intérieur de la masse et boe s'est
articulée avec le bras donc little foot
est vraiment un spécimen absolument
complet complet à 90 % quand lucie donc
qui est le probablement
l'australopithèque le plus connu n'est
complet qu'à 40% ou bien vous avez aussi
australopithecus sediba je ne sais pas
jusqu'à quel point il est complet mais
on a un très beau crâne
l'australopithecus sediba mais il est
déjà aussi un peu plus complet que
l'uci est alors un truc qu'il faut
savoir c'est que le tout premier
australopithecus découvert la premier
spécimen qui a donné son nom à un
australopithecus c'est l'enfant de tang
donc c'est celui-là c'est cet
australopithèque eu cela qui a été
découvert en 1924 en afrique du sud
donc c'est pas lui si le premier
australopithèques c'est l'enfant de tang
qui appartient australopithecus
africanus voilà donc c'est avec la
découverte de l'enfant de tang qu'on a
commencé à envisager une origine
africaine de la lignée humaine
lucie n'étant venu que bien des années
après confirmer cette hypothèse
donc les australopithèques signer ce
qu'on sait de on s'est énormément de
choses d'eux mais je ne peux pas tout
dire dans une diapo mais en gros ils ont
un petit cerveau ce qui est plutôt
primitif le pouce dieu le pouce sur le
pied est toujours opposable mais les
jambes sont désormais plus longue que
les bras on le sait grâce à little foot
donc on a une bipédie complète est
assurée chez chez les australopithèques
et on a au niveau du palais donc une
morphologie qui est intermédiaire donc
allant de pair avec la réduction des
canines le palais devient de moins en
moins rectangulaire et chez les
australopithèques signer on a vraiment
un mix entre le palais rectangulaire et
le palais paraboliques ou arrondie du
genre humain donc le et évidemment vous
voyez que le le museau se réduit aussi
par rapport au reste par contre la
morphologie du cerveau la morphologie du
cerveau reste primitivement d'environ
400 centimètres cubes chez les
australopithèques il ya une chose qu'on
va voir un peu plus tard pendant cette
présentation mais c'est que quand je
parle des australopithèques en fait je
devrais pas parler des australopithèques
là je vous fais je vous fais une
synthèse en gros qui est basée sur
australopithecus afarensis qui est basée
sur australopithecus prometheus donc
little foot et sur australopithecus
africanus qui sont vraiment les trois
australopithèques les mieux connus et
qui ont été le plus étudié mais la
vérité c'est que si vous si vous prenez
la totalité des australopithèques qui a
peut-être autant de diversité au sein
des australopithèques qu'il y en a dans
tout le reste de la lignée humaine
enfin dans tout le reste de l'arbre
phylogénétique humain parce que les
australopithèques c1 c'est ce qu'on
appelle un taxon poubelle c'est à dire
que tout ce qui ressemble suffisamment à
un humain mais qui n'est pas du genre
homo a été peu ou prou caser dans
australopithèques us voilà ce qui fait
que l'australopithèque lucy les définit
essentiellement par des caractère
primitif donc typiquement à chaque fois
que vous sortez un nouvel hominidé avec
un cerveau de 400 centimètres cube c'est
automatiquement casey chez
australopithecus à chaque fois que vous
sortez un homininés qui a qui a qui
présente quelques adaptations à la vie
arboricole il est tout de suite exclu du
genre homo est placé chez
australopithèques us
c'est ce qui s'est passé avec
australopithecus sediba australopithecus
sediba à une mâchoire il a un museau
extrêmement courts une mâchoire
extrêmement gracile des dents tout petit
ap allait fortement paraboliques donc
quasiment quasiment au même niveau que
homo que les homo habilis par exemple
mais parce qu'il a un cerveau de 400
centimètres cubes et qu'il a une
anatomie de l'épaule qui indiquent un
mode de vie arboricole il a été placé
parmi eux australopithèques us ce qui
est éminemment ce qui est éminemment pas
bien parce que on ne classe on ne classe
pas les espèces avec des caractères
primitif s'il arboricole y est un
caractère primitif
alors on devrait faire des
australopithecus sediba représentants du
genre homo et c'est ce qu'on verra un
peu plus tard je vous montrerai tout ça
sur une file au génie où vous verrez
qu'en fait australopithecus c'est un
assemblage profondément pas monofil
éthique pour ne pas dire poli fit
carrément poliphile éthiques
voilà donc il est fort probable que la
taxonomie d'australopithèques us et à
changer dans le futur
sachant que dans le futur si australo
pitt
eq us devait subir une révision
taxonomique l'enfant de tang serait le
point de repère pour tout le genre
australopithecus puisque c'est le
premier à avoir été découvertes
voilà donc comme je vous le disais les
australopithèques conserve un cerveau
relativement petit de l'ordre de 400 à
500 centimètres cubes et ils ont une
mâchoire extrêmement large et puissante
vous pouvez voir sauf australopithecus
sediba mais je voulais dit c'est lui là
c'est un cas à part
et ils ont donc grâce aux empreintes de
pieds de là et au lit en tanzanie on
sait que au moins un australopithecus
afarensis avait un pouce opposable
convoiterait très bien ici par rapport
aux autres doigts du pied et que se
pousse d'ailleurs toujours opposable
était relativement petit con correspond
comparé aux autres doigts alors que si
on compare ses empreintes aux empreintes
de homo erectus que vous voyez que vous
voyez ici et bien les empreintes d'homo
erectus ont un très gros pouce ont une
voûte plantaire et ont des orteils qui
sont plus petits que le pouce et le
pousser parfaitement alignés avec le
reste du pied donc le pouce n'est plus
du tout opposable chez homo erectus et
est donc chez homo erectus vous avez
aussi donc le cerveau qui va grossir
donc chez le genre homo de manière
générale le cerveau va va grossir
en moyenne il double de taille
évidemment ce n'est pas le cas chez tous
les genres au mot on va voir qu'il ya
des homos qui on a un peu échappé à la
règle notamment homo habilis homo
habilis a un cerveau de 600 centimètres
cubes
mais après avec homo erectus on passe
sur détail de cerveau de 800 à 1000 cm
cube et en double encore la taille du
cerveau une fois chez
chez les homo sapiens et homo
neandertalensis au moins deux
libériennes 6 dans ce qu'on appelle les
homos tardif voilà donc la taille du
cerveau la tendance est très simple vous
doublez une fois chez homo et vous chez
les premiers homo et vous doublez encore
une fois chez les les homos les plus d
arrivée et puis le et pour définir le
genre homo on utilise aussi évidemment
le non alignement de enfin l'alignement
du gros orteil avec le reste du pied ce
qui correspond à la disparition du pouce
opposable
donc voilà si vous cherchez les
caractères qui définissent homos c'est
taille du cerveau plus grosse que chez
les australopithèques signer donc au
moins six ans un centimètre cube pour
homo habilis le pouce qui n'est plus
opposable sur le pied l'ama les le pouce
de la main qui devient plus grands et
qui commence et qui permet d'attraper
des objets avec l'index et la gracilité
de la mâchoire qu'on retrouve aussi chez
australopithecus sediba mais la
gracilité de la mâchoire et
définitivement quelque chose qui qui va
avec le genre homo donc
la grâce une mâchoire relativement
gracile vous voyez par rapport aux
doigts du monsieur c'est pas c'est pas
bien épais comme mâchoire et vous voyez
les dents qui sont relativement petite
comparée à celle d'un australopithèque
regardez là la puissance de cette
mâchoire la taille des dents les dents
sont très très grosse démo l'air sont
très très grosse chez australopithèques
comparé au genre homo donc les molaires
sont relativement réduite chez le genre
homo est ici vous pouvez vous pouvez
voir aussi avec cette courbure que le la
mâchoire était plutôt arrondies et non
pas carré et puis vous voyez c'est tout
petit câline évidemment donc tout ça ça
définit le genre homo et la gracilité de
la mâchoire notamment va de pair avec
elle va de pair avec l'usagé d'outils
lusa l'usagé d'outils qui est documenté
des 3,6 millions d'années si je me
rappelle bien 3,6 ou 3,2 millions
d'années on en reparlera après de
l'usagé d'outils mais voilà on sait que
des australopithèques signer et non et
gagnent entre opus en particulier devait
déjà utilisé des outils et donc
l'utilisation prolongée d'outils par les
représentants de la lignée humaine
eh bien ça finit par provoquer cette
réduction de la mâchoire
pourquoi parce que tout simplement vous
prédis gérer votre nourriture à
l'extérieur de votre bouche en découpant
votre nourriture tout simplement
voilà donc celle après digestion de la
nourriture par l'usagé d'outils a eu des
effets biologiques et anatomiques non
négligeable sur la lignée humaine est la
raison pour laquelle je vous montre
cette ce bout de mâchoire dégueulasse
plutôt qu'avec un beau fossiles c'est
parce que c'est ce fossile n'est ni plus
ni moins que le plus ancien fossile du
genre homo qui datent de 2,8 millions
d'années donc 2,8 millions d'années il y
avait encore beaucoup
d'australopithèques sur terrain
si je vous montre par exemple sediba
sediba et le date de deux millions
d'années le temps que j'aille lille à
2,5 millions d'années donc il était
content pour largement contemporain du
genre en eau et là vous avez dans la
celui-là australopithecus prometheus il
est trop vieux mais voilà vous aviez de
pas mal de représentants du genre
australopithèques us qui vivait encore
il ya 2,8 millions d'années donc il y
avait plein de lignées humaines en
parallèle qu'il ya plein de l'espèce
humaine qui vivait en parallèle y
compris le genre homo en même temps que
d'autres représentants
d'australopithèques us voilà c'est ce
que je vous disais là le precision
grippe la capacité de pouvoir attraper
avec l'index et le pouce là elle est
très très bien illustré ici et donc
puisqu'on parle des tout premiers
représentants du genre humain c'est le
moment de parler d' homo naledi parce
que mona les lilas il associe pour lui
qu'il associe beaucoup de caractère
primitif avec des caractères typiquement
humain donc lé caractère primitif les
plus évidents basse et la taille du
cerveau de mona lee 10 1 entre 400 et
600 centimètres cubes en fait entre 400
et 450 et 550 en fait il ya deux
spécimens qui font respectivement 450 et
550 centimètres cubes
donc c'est un cerveau qui est
définitivement dans la gamme de
variation des australopithèques
intermédiaire avec homo habilis j'ai
envie de dire donc il serait même plus
basale comobilis de ce point de vue là
vous avez une problématique mme encore
important chez homo naledi vous pouvez
voir ici ce petit tyran renflement qui
montrent qu'ils avaient quand même un
petit museau jeu monaldi la face n'est
pas totalement plate comme chez les
autres représentants du genre homo il ya
encore un petit museau qui traîne mais
là le palais est définitivement
parabolique et un autre caractère
primitif que vous avez chez homo naledi
c'est que les phalanges des mâts sont
encore courbé donc au moins à lady était
encore adapté à la braque à sion mais
par contre le pied est définitivement
celui d'un humain vous voyez que le gros
orteil est aligné avec les autres
orteils et est très
très gros comparé au reste des orteils
donc c'est le doit porter de charges un
pied qui est donc adapté à marcher voire
même à courir un petit peu et sur la
main vous pouvez voir le pouce qui est
relativement développée quand même
équipe eux devaient permettre cette
précision grippe que vous pouvez voir
ici donc on a tous cet assortiment
finalement de caractère
d'australopithèques signer adaptation à
lavaur e-coli petits cerveaux et des
caractères aussi deux homos typique du
genre donc les petites dans la mâchoire
la mâchoire plutôt faibles plutôt grâce
il le pousse non opposable sur le pied
donc voilà tout ça ça s'associent chez
une espèce une espèce qui est représenté
par beaucoup d'individus il ya quinze
individus qui ont été découverts donc
c'est beaucoup plus que n'importe quel
homo habilis et il ya beaucoup plus de
fossiles aussi que d'homo habilis ya
plus de quinze mille fragments fossiles
qui ont été découverts en tout incluant
de crâne dont 1 quasiment complet donc
c'est la part comparé aux mobilis et
déjà vachement mieux je crois pas qu'on
ait vraiment de crâne décemment complet
de d'homo habilis où on en a peut-être
un à la limite qui a permis de voir la
taille du cerveau
si mes souvenirs sont exacts donc et
c'est une espèce qui a été découvert
éminemment récemment puisqu'il a été
découvert en 2015 donc c'est une
découverte toute neuve du qui vient de
des alentours de johannesburg du cradle
of humankind du berceau de l'humanité en
anglais en français donc
donc ça montre aussi le potentiel du
berceau de l'humanité pour la halle pour
la découverte de nouveaux fossiles
important donc voilà au monal et 10 dans
sa dans son anatomie
il est à peu près du même calibre comeau
habilis mais en mieux documenter on va
dire le seul problème de pomona les 10
et son âge il a deux cent cinquante
mille ans et c'est tout entre 250000 et
300 mille ans et c'est tout il n'a pas
il n'a pas 2,5 voire 2,6 millions
d'années comme on s'attendait à ce
qu'ils étaient censés elle
avoir d'après son anatomie bon c'est pas
un problème en soi ça veut juste dire
que homo naledi à l'époque où il a vécu
c'était un fossile vivant
voilà c'est tout mais la ligne est
finalement la racine évolutif de aumône
ali dit elle
elle doit avoir 2 5 millions d'années
puisque comme je le dis au monal est dit
est très semblable à homo habilis dans
son anatomie et on a et on a deux et on
a de très voilé on a une main qui est
tout articulé on a un pied qui est tout
articulé on a au moins deux crânes dont
un complet donc il est il est tout aussi
voire plus intéressants comme au habilis
parce qu on a beaucoup plus de beau
matériel de mona lee dit puisqu'il ya
d'intéressant avec common à l'e10 est là
l'hypothèse qui a été proposé que d'une
d'une en fait que les hormones à lady
aurait ce serait débarrasser des corps
de leurs congénères de façon volontaire
non parce que tous les tous les restes
d'homo naledi ont été découverts dans la
même grotte et au monal est dit est le
seul animal qu'on trouve dans cette
grotte et ce à des assemblages mono
spécifique de fossiles d'homininés il y
en a qu'un seul enfin il ya qu un seul
cas de figure qu'on connaît et ça
s'appelle un cimetière
voilà donc donc quand on en trouve dans
une grotte tout un tas de faux cils
15000 fossiles et que tous appartiennent
à la même espèce de mini bar faut
commencer à se poser des questions au
niveau de la taphonomie quoi et là on
est possiblement face à un exemple il ya
205 250 millions d'années de 150000 à
300 milles en 2g 10 millions d'années de
250000 à 300 mille ans oui mais
attention ce reprenez mois si jamais je
me trompe
donc voilà ce serait le plus vieux
exemple de 2,2 d'hominidés qui se
débarrasse en fait des corps de leurs
congénères on peut pas vraiment dire
qu'il y avait un rituel parce que les
corps n'étaient pas particulièrement
arranger on peut voir dans la grotte qui
a eu beaucoup de remaniements en fait
les eaux se sont très mal et parce que
le niveau des eaux a alors les ossements
se sont ravalés parce que le niveau de
l'eau dans la grotte le niveau de la
nappe phréatique a varié dans la grotte
et à transporter les eaux donc on peut
pas voir s'ils étaient bien organisés
comme dans une vraie tombe de néandertal
par exemple voilà une une tombe de
néandertal qui datent de cent mille ans
et qui jusque là étaient parmi les plus
vieux exemple vous
de vrais tombe qu'on pour lequel on est
sûr on a aussi des tombes d'homo sapiens
qui auraient entre 100 et 300 mille ans
et qui viennent du moyen-orient dont les
dates sont pas sont pas pour celle de
300 mille ans on n'est pas sûr sûr mais
il est possible qu'on ait aussi des
tombes qui sont vieilles de trois cent
mille ans donc là quand vous vous
trouvez un corps comme ça évidemment il
ya pas trop de doutes sur le fait qu'on
est sur du conte est en train de
regarder une tombe je veux dire le corps
est vraiment placée d'une façon
particulière qui montrent qu'il ya eu
volonté de de prendre soin de ce corps
bon au monal est dit on sait pas mais
possiblement en serait donc face à l'un
des plus anciens exemple de rites
funéraires si on arrivait si on arrive à
jour trouvé deux peut-être pas de riz
funéraire mais au moins deux oueds de
volonté de traiter ces morts
différemment voilà et de pas juste les
laisser dehors à pourrir donc on arrive
maintenant solidement dans le genre homo
donc comme je disais aux monnaies les
dix ce serait pas remis parmi les
hominidés les plus les plus basses eaux
au moins comparable à homo habilis donc
homo habilis qui a vécu entre 2,1 et 1,5
million d'années qu'on reconnaît comme
un membre du genre homo non pas par sa
taille de cerveau puisque son cerveau
est relativement petit lait entre 500 et
600 centimètres cubes donc un poil plus
grand que common à lady et les
australopithèques mais pas de beaucoup
mais on le reconnaît surtout à sa
dentition qui est gracile et à sa
musculature donc qui est qui est aussi
relativement réduite
vous voyez le crâne le plus complet de
homo habilis ça ça paye pas de mine
quand même s'est il n'y a pas beaucoup
de matériel de homo habilis simple de
homo habilis et un peu ça le problème
donc ce qu'on sait de ce qu'on sait du
genre homo vient surtout de homo
ergaster et de homo erectus donc homo
ergaster étant le pendant africains de
homo erectus et homo erectus étant le
pendant asiatique d'homo ergaster il ya
certaines personnes qui veulent placer
homo erectus et homo ergaster dans le
même genre
enfin dans la même espèce homo ergaster
s'est débattu homo ergaster du coup
de par sa racines africaines l'ancêtre
direct des homos plus dérivés donc
notamment homo heidelbergensis qui
ultime m'en donnera homo sapiens c'est
pour ça que des fois vous entendre et
dire aux gens que homo ergaster est le
vrai ancêtres d'homo sapiens bon c'est
juste que voilà il était au bon endroit
au bon moment mais ça veut pas forcément
dire que c'est lui l'ancêtre donc l'homo
ergaster donc l'homo l'homo erectus
africa si on veut il a vécu entre 1,9 et
1,4 million d'années l'exemple typique
c'est le turkana boy donc l'enfant du
turkana sne le crâne que vous voyez ici
qui a donc un cerveau de 8 centimètres
cubes donc c'est un cerveau qui est
quand même relativement petit pour le
genre homo mais qui est déjà deux fois
plus gros que celui de
l'australopithèque de base vous voyez
donc les molaires qui sont réduites en
fait ça donne même l'impression qu'il a
des énormes incisive tellement les
molaires sont réduites je sais pas si ça
vous fait cet effet là mais voilà là
pour le coup je sais le turkana boys on
voit très bien la réduction des molaires
parce que ça on a l'impression du coup
qu'il a des incisives de lapin quoi et
homo erectus du coup donc dont vous
pouvez voir qu'il a un cerveau beaucoup
plus gros là pour le coup ça se voit
très très bien donc homo erectus
il a été découvert en asie donc le tout
premier homo erectus c'est l'homme de
java et l'homo erectus que je vous
montre la cessoie l'homme de java soit
l'homme de pékin donc vous pouvez voir
que les homo erectus typique
ils ont tous été découvert en asie et
genre très très loin en asie papa en
asie un côté de l'afrique non très
profondément en asie et ils ont été on
commence à les trouver à partir de 1,8
million d'années et ils ont pu persister
jusqu'à il ya 80 mille ans en indonésie
donc 1,8 million d'années
ce sont les premiers homo erectus qui
viennent de géorgie donc que certains
ont envie d'appeler au mot géorgie cus
pour pas compliquer les affaires
mais voilà les tout premiers homo
erectus hors d'afrique
c'est 1,8 million d'années donc
quasiment voilà vous avez le genre homo
qui appareille à 2,8 millions d'années
homo ergaster qui apparaît à 1,9 million
d'années est homo erectus qui un million
d'années après l'apparition du premier
homo comment commence à quitter
l'afrique voilà ils quittent l'afrique
il va en europe
il va en
il va surtout en asie homo erectus il va
un peu en europe mais il va pas aller
très très loin en europe il va pas aller
en europe de l'est de l'ouest il va
rester en europe de l'est je crois que
va pas aller bien loin de la géorgie et
après il va s'étendre très très loin en
asie jusqu'en indonésie justement là où
on va retrouver les derniers
représentants qui ont possiblement
jusqu'à 80 mille ans et si vous
considérez que
si vous considérez que l'homme de florès
est le descendant d'un homo erectus
asiatiques
ça vous amène même jusqu'à 50000 en donc
voila et homo erectus a définitivement
une phase bien plate un bourrelet sus
orbitaire très développés alors ce qui
va le distinguer homo erectus asiatiques
de son pendant africain ça va être comme
je disais la taille du cerveau qui fait
au moins 800 cm cube et jusqu'à 1200
centimètres cube pour les plus gros
alors là on est quasiment au niveau de
l' homo sapiens donc homo erectus de son
côté va évoluer un gros cerveau en
parallèle de homo sapiens donc ça c'est
plutôt intéressant mais ce qui va
différencier homo erectus des autres
l'homo erectus asiatique des autres homo
ça va être les crêtes qu'il a sur le
côté vous voyez là donc il a une
musculature de la mâchoire qui
s'insèrent ici qui est beaucoup plus
puissantes que celles d'homo ergaster ou
d'homo habilis et vous pouvez voir les
dents qui sont aussi assez costaud au
final
globalement réduite comparé à un
australopithèque mais assez costaud donc
voilà là c'est l'histoire que je vous
disais donc homo erectus apparaît en a
mais en a en afrique il y à 1,9 2
millions d'années et il se répand enfin
homo erectus
homo ergaster pardon apparaît en afrique
il ya 1,9 million d'années on pense que
homo erectus est apparu dans ces coins
là dans ces eaux là aussi mais homo
erectus lui s'est dispersée vers l'asie
et on en retrouve justement on les
retrouve à demain ici en géorgie il y à
1.7 millions d'années déjà et maintenant
on a même alors là vous aviez déjà une
possible l'occurrence à 2 millions
d'années au pakistan mais maintenant de
ce côté-ci en chine
ils ont découvert des restes des outils
qui ont 2,1 millions d'années donc il
est possible même comment eric tu sois
sorti d'asile soient sortis d'afrique il
y à 2,1 millions d'années donc voilà et
l'homme de java donc et il a atteint
java d'ores et déjà 1,8 million d'années
voilà est alors à propos de l'homme de à
propos de géorgie justement je vous ai
parlé de la possibilité que l'homme de
géorgie forment une espèce à part
entière qui serait au mot géorgiques us
ben c'est parce que au début on
connaissait des crânes domo géorgie cus
qui était très différent des crânes
d'homo erectus est asiatique et et
d'homo ergaster africain mais sauf que
donc au début on voulait en faire une
espèce à part et puis on a découvert
d'autres crâne et maintenant on a un
deux trois quatre cinq crâne qui
viennent de géorgie qui viennent tous du
même site qui s'appelle hodgman ici qui
datent de 1,7 à 1,8 million d'années et
donc et vous pouvez voir que ces crânes
et bah ils sont très différents les uns
des autres bons déjà parce que vous avez
possiblement des juvéniles et des très
vieux spécimens mais vous pouvez voir
que chez les spécimens adultes moyens
comme celui ci est celui là vous avez
des spécimens qui ont un cerveau
relativement gros et des mâchoires
relativement faibles ou ou bien un
cerveau relativement petit et des
mâchoires relativement grosse voix là
vous voyez là gros cerveau gros cerveau
petit cerveau petit cerveau petit
mâchoire bon là c'est un vieux alors ça
compte pas petit mâchoire petit mâchoire
énorme mâchoire et vous pouvez voir ici
pareil
la différence de forme du crâne qui est
qui est très très en fait ce qu'on
retrouve avec ces homo erectus ou
géorgie cus c'est une énorme variabilité
qui recouvre complètement la variabilité
d'homo ergaster domo rudolf n 6 et de
homo erectus et homo rudolfensis j'en ai
pas parlé parce que c'est un spécimen à
part voilà il ya qu un seul spécimen et
c'est pas bien connu ça pourrait être
juste un variant d'homo ergaster mais
maintenant du coup avec la découverte de
tous ces hominidés de géorgie qui
semblent ils ont tous été retrouvés dans
le même trou je veux dire un voilà c'est
ça ils ont tous été retrouvés dans le
même trou dont il n'y a pas vraiment
beaucoup de doutes quant au fait qu'ils
appartiennent tous à la même espèce mais
s'ils appartiennent tous à la même
espèce
c'est une espèce dont la variabilité
recouvre allègrement tout la variabilité
qu'on a entre ergaster rudolf n 6 et
erectus d'asie et ça ça fout la merde ça
ça devrait vouloir dire ça ça rajoute de
l'eau au moulin de ceux qui disent que
ergaster et rudolf n 6 et ce sont des
erectus
donc voilà le problème c'est que erectus
maintenant enfin si vous suivez un peu
facile vous avez un peu si vous avez un
peu suivi ce que j'ai dit avant erectus
c'est une espèce qui a été définie à
partir de l'homme de java c'est à dire
un homo erectus un peu comme ça avec des
gros secrètes sur le côté du crâne et un
cerveau de taille assez volumineuse de
l'ordre de 1000 cm cube et inclure homo
ergaster qui a huit centimètres cubes et
qui n'a pas ses crêtes sur le côté dans
la même espèce comeau erectus qui a les
crêtes et un gros cerveau ça pique un
peu ça pique un peu donc je peux
comprendre les deux points de vue en
fait je comprends les deux points de vue
ceux qui disent que vu qu'on a de la
maxe de variabilité c'est la même espèce
et ceux qui disent que ouais mais on
peut pas se résoudre à [ __ ] celui
d'afrique en même temps dans le même
groupe que celui d'asie d'autant que
celui d'afrique encore une fois
géographiquement parlant il ya une forte
probabilité qu'il ait donné naissance à
ultima mans à la ligne et d'homo sapiens
alors que celui d'asie on sait que c'est
un cul de sac évolutif on sait que il il
a possiblement donner au mot luçonnais
donc cette nouvelle espèce qui a été
découvert encore une fois par des
français d'ailleurs sur l'île de des
philippines et les ce2 et homo
floresiensis qui a été découverte sur
l'île de flores quoi donc ça c'est
possiblement des descendants des rictus
mais qui ont fini par s'éteindre donc ça
fait quand même d'homo erectus un
cul-de-sac évolutif et du coup ça fait
mal de m omer gaster dans le même sac
que le cul de sac évolutif quoi donc bon
c'est affaire à suivre
affaire à suivre tout ça c'est des
découvertes récentes la découverte de
tous ces crânes de géorgie lacets 2013
donc c'est tout ça c'est très récent du
point de vue de la recherche du mois je
sais bien qu'en 2013 internet considère
que 2013 c'était le paléolithique mais
non c'est pas comme ça que ça marche la
recherche
et voilà la fameuse phylogénie du coup
pour remettre un peu d'ordre dans tout
ça donc on a vu
toumaï qui vient ici ardipithecus qui
vient là donc et après on a vu les
australopithèques et du coup vous avez
australopithèques and à mennecy ce qui
est le plus ancien et le plus banal qui
définit le début du clad
australopithèques us oui mais le clad
australopithèques us il contient kenyan
trop puce il contient pas rentrer opus
pas rentrer au plus qui est le groupe
frère d'australopithecus africanus et il
contient aux mots aux mots à l'intérieur
duquel on trouve australopithecus sediba
aux côtés de homo habilis me voyez là
donc
donc c'est ce que je vous disais
australopithecus c'est un groupe qui a
besoin d'être retravaillées
c'est vraiment un
c'est vraiment un sac un sac de noeuds à
cerner mais lab l'australopithèque us et
ultimement si on finit par donner des
noms différents atouts ces
australopithèques et ben il va falloir
au final le seul australopithecus valide
ce sera l'enfant de tongs
voilà donc australopithecus africanus en
l'occurrence donc voila et les seuls cas
d' clac bien défini c'est pas rentrer
plus parce qu'à l'intérieur de part
entre opus on retrouve ethiopiques us
robustus et bouazzi qui appartiennent
bien au club pas entre opus est à la
limite si on veut bien admettre que
australopithecus sediba et et le genre
homo et bien on a un beau clad qui est
défini le genre moudon con c'est là
qu'on voit qu'en fait le le genre homo
est défini par des caractères dérivés
donc la gracile isation de la mâchoire
la réduction de la face le pouce
opposable perdu sur le pied et le pousse
allongé sur la main par entre opus lui
il est bien défini par les caractères
qu'on va voir juste après parce qu'on va
parler de pas rentrer au plus juste
après mais il est très très bien définit
aussi par des caractères dérivés et on
ne classe pas du coup avec des
caractères primitif parce que sinon ça
vous donne australopithecus voilà si ça
a un petit cerveau etc arboricole ces
australopithèques us et non mauvaise
réponse donc et surtout ce que j'aime
bien avec cet arbre massé qui vous
montre qu'il ya plein de lignées
d'hominidés qui ont vécu en même temps
parce que cet arbre vous voyez les
calibrer dans le temps vous avez des
millions d'années en bas donc vous
pouvez voir comme m au même moment vous
aviez africanus part entre opus est homo
qui vivait pousse tous en même temps et
en même temps que australopithecus gary
locke
donc voilà là ça permet de bien voir
combien de lignes et pouvait vivre en
même temps comme je vous l ai dit tout à
l'heure avec le genre homo qui peut
remonter jusqu'à 2,8 millions d'années
pour les plus anciens fossiles donc on
serait plus le plus ancien fossile il
serait là donc antérieurs à homo habilis
et des âges de divergence qui serait
encore plus anciens voyez donc c'est ça
qui est bien avec cet abcès qui permet
de voir combien de l'espèce humaine ont
pu vivre en même temps et du coup à quel
point la diversité des espèces humaines
aujourd'hui et pauvres est donc là où je
voudrais attirer votre attention et bien
c'est sûr pas rentrer opus justement
puisque part entre opus apparaît peu ou
prou au même moment que homo il y à 2 5
millions da
donc 2,8 millions d'années pour le plus
ancien au mans et il va disparaître peu
ou prou qu au moment où va apparaître
homo erectus bon donc il a vécu il a
largement cohabiter avec homo habilis et
alors ce qui caractérise par entre opus
mais bien ce sont ces énormes dans donc
déjà il va
contrairement à homo part entre opus va
partir dans la direction opposée niveau
dentaire il va avoir des dents encore
plus grosse que celle de deux
australopithèques us il va avoir une
énorme crête sagittale donc le petit
truc que vous pouvez voir ici la crête
sagittale qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs
aussi chez chez toumaï alors chez toumaï
c'était un caractère hérité directement
des gorilles des deschiens pas et qui
avait disparu ensuite chez tous les
australopithèques les kenyans trope et
le genre homo mais qui refait son
apparition chez part entre opus et cette
crête sagittale c'est le point la tâche
des normes muscles mastic ateurs pour
faire aller la mâchoire extrêmement
puissante sur la mâchoire la mâchoire
inférieure sur la mâchoire supérieure et
en plus de 7 de ce muscle temporal
extrêmement puissant vous avez ici les
arcade zygomatique qui sont très très
hot
vous pouvez voir qu'ils sont très épais
ce parce qu'à l'intérieur de ces arcade
zygomatique vous avez le muscle master
donc le muscle déjoue qui sert aussi à
mastiquer dans ce qu'on appelle aussi le
muscles zygomatiques
donc vous avez une énorme adaptation à
la mastication chez part entre opus donc
là ça se voit très bien sur ce diagramme
vous avez les australopithèques ici les
parents trope ici est homo habilis ici
donc vous avez à la base une morphologie
d'australopithèques qui chez homo
habilis vasseux grassi lisez pour donner
donc ce palais ce palais semi
circulaires et ses dents plutôt fine et
la disparition
enfin le lac raid sagittale qui n'est de
toute façon déjà plus lâcher les
australopithèques qui a été perdue
depuis ça il entre aux puces et chez pas
rentrer aux puces au final bas vous vous
voyez réapparaître la craie de sagittale
qui sert d'insertion aux énormes muscles
mastic ateurs vous voyez c'est énorme
arcade zygomatique qui eux aussi ça va
attacher des muscles matic est
l'instigateur la mâchoire qui devient
épaisse très profonde au niveau de
l'angle pour l'insertion de ses muscles
là sur la mâchoire justement donc les
muscles qui viennent ça sert ici et ses
muscles là qui viennent s'insérer ici
des dents extrêmement grosse même
comparé à australopithecus donc là on
parle de mes gars dont six à palais qui
est extrêmement rectangulaire malgré
d'ailleurs la réduction des canines donc
pas rentrer opus
c'est un animal très particulier et il
doit ses particularités au fait qu'il
qu'il est herbivore il est totalement
herbivores donc la surface mastic à
trice des dents des dents de part entre
opus a augmenté pour augmenter la
surface occlusale pour pouvoir mâcher de
la nourriture coriace ce qui va de pair
avec le développement des muscles donc
c'est vraiment une tout ça c'est de
l'adaptation à une nourriture coriace à
base de cellulose parce que par entre
opus était définitivement un herbivore
donc vous avez ici une analyse de la
chimie isotopique des dents chez les
hominidés donc envers vous avez les
australopithèques en jaune vous avez les
parents trope et en rouge vous avez les
le genre homo donc vous voyez là déjà la
synchronicité du genre homo avec le
genre part entre hop et le genre
australopithecus et ensuite la
disparition d'australopithecus avec la
synchronicité des homos qui vivait en
même temps que les parents trope
paranthropus robustus notamment est donc
là ce que vous avez de ce côté là c'est
l'analyse isotopique donc l'analyse de
la chimio osseuse et dentaire plutôt
dentaire dans ce cas là est donc ce que
vous voyez ici c'est pas rentrer up donc
pas rentrer up qui a qui recouvre une
très très large gamme finalement de
chimie isotopique montrant que c'était
plutôt un omnivore
c'était un omnivore assez franche ou
francs avec peut-être tendance herbivore
étant donné la grosse taille de ses
dents et puis plus tard une fois que les
australopithèques us ont laissé place à
homo et à part entre up et bien vous
avez une distinction qui s'opèrent
distinction entre parents trope d'un
côté et aux mots de l'autre et cette
distinction en fait et bien c'est une
distinction entre des parents trope de
plus en plus herbivore et des homos de
plus en plus carnivore et ça c'est ça
c'est très intéressant et c'est et c'est
exactement ce que nous raconte la
morphologie au final donc pas rentrer
opus assez énorme muscles c'est énorme
dans pour qu'ils augmentent la puissance
de la mastication pour la nourriture
coriace à base de cellulose et vous
pouvez voir une très forte usure des
dents qui est dû au fait que bah il
mangé de l'herbe des graminées et que
ces graminées sont riches en silice qui
bouffe complètement les dents alors que
chez homo habilis vous avez
des dents qui sont beaucoup plus gracile
qui sont faits qui sont un peu plus
adapté finalement une nourriture
beaucoup plus tendre déjà qu'ils étaient
qui était déjà prédit gérés par des
outils mais qui devait être en plus
plus tendre de manière générale donc
plus riches en viande on va dire donc
cette l'apparition d'un régime carnivore
se fait chez le genre homo et du coup
elle a été ce que ce que vous avez ici
en fait c'est un exemple vraiment de
partitions des niches c'est ça qui est
très intéressant en fait ici c'est que
vous avez cet exemple de partitions des
niches donc à la question comment les
espèces les différentes espèces
d'hominidés arrivé à cohabiter sur le
même territoire africain
sans ce sans se gêner et bien il y avait
cette partition dénicher ils se
partageaient les ressources et 7 se
partage des ressources a fini par
aboutir à la à l'apparition de deux
lignes et la lignée des humains
fortement herbivores les parents trope
et la lignée des humains plus carnivore
un peu plus carnivore toujours omnivore
à vous voyez que ça reste alignée avec
la moyenne des australopithèques donc
toujours omnivore mais à tendance plus
carnivore chez le genre homo donc ce qui
va nous intéresser maintenant dans cette
seconde partie de cours le cours à trois
parties donc dans cette seconde partie
de course on va s'intéresser maintenant
l'évolution du cerveau à l'intelligence
et aux techniques
non pas que ça ait un lien direct avec
le régime alimentaire de ne pas rentrer
aux puces ou deux et de homo je veux
dire évidemment il ya cette théorie
selon laquelle les humains en devenant
carnivores ont développé un plus gros
cerveau mais bon la vérité c'est que le
cerveau il a besoin de sucre pas
tellement de protéines donc je vois pas
vraiment pourquoi les gens sont partis
sur cette idée mais bref une nourriture
plus riche en tout cas est plus
diversifiée et certainement est
certainement à l'origine a certainement
soutenu le développement du cerveau chez
homo contrairement à part entre up qui
avait une nourriture plus tôt
plutôt pauvre en nutriments genre a donc
il faut beaucoup de il faut beaucoup
beaucoup d'herbe pour enfin de végétaux
pour arriver à acquérir autant d'énergie
que quand on est omnivore
voilà donc quand on est omnivore on est
aussi un peu plus flexible donc d'en
haut niveau de son régime alimentaire
est tous à la flexibilité du régime
alimentaire ça a pu aussi jouer un rôle
dans le développement du cerveau mais
tout ça ce n'est que spéculation bien
sûr ce qu'il faut dire aussi c'est que
par entre opus était pas strictement
herbivores il y avait des espèces qui
étaient à herbivores dont grammy nivore
il y avait des espèces qu'ils mangeaient
des turbans tubercules et des noix donc
les tubercules et les noix c'est quand
ça reste de la rue de la nourriture
relativement riche quand même et ça
encore une fois on le sait grâce aux
analyses géochimiques donc l'évolution
de l'intelligence et des techniques chez
l'humain donc tout ça ça va évidemment
de pair avec l'évolution du cerveau donc
comme je voulais dit on démarre avec un
cerveau deux
alors de la taille de celui d'un
australopithèque alors pas rentrer opus
conserve un cerveau de taille
australopithèques ya donc entre 400 et
500 centimètres cubes
et puis vous passez à homo habilis qui
monte dans les six ans donc les petits
triangles donc homo habilis monde dans
les six ans et puis d'un seul coup bim
fou ça la taille du cerveau moyens
double c'est le passage à homo erectus
slash au moins à basse-terre et donc
chez homo erectus et homo ergaster
notamment les homos irait chez les homo
erectus d'asie vous allez avoir une
tendance justement à l'augmentation de
la taille du cerveau jusqu'à atteindre
des tailles de cerveau qui comme vous
voyez rivalisent avec les humains
modernes donc les homo erectus d'asie
vont avoir une tendance au développement
parallèle de la taille du cerveau
jusqu'à détail quasiment sapiens et donc
ça c'est ce qui arrive en asie et
pendant ce temps là en afrique vous avez
et dahlberg m6 et dahlberg n 6 qui va
apparaître
il y a de cela entre 500 et 600 mille
ans et et d'albert gagnent 6 il va
donner homo sapiens et homo
neandertalensis qui eux ont des cerveaux
de très grande taille
vous voyez même néandertal n 6 ayant en
moyenne un cerveau plus grand de l'ordre
de 1500 centimètre cube que l'homme
moderne qui en moyenne un cerveau de
1400 centimètres cubes bon tout ça c'est
des moyennes évidemment vous voyez qu'il
ya des néandertal qui ont un petit
cerveau il ya des sapiens qui ont un
petit cerveau il ya des sapiens qu un
gros cerveau il ya des néandertal comme
un très gros cerveau aussi mais voilà
donc l'évolution du cerveau c'est pas
une augmentation qui est linéaire ses
poufs sa double une première fois et
pouf sa double encore chez les
asiatiques et pouf sarr double encore
chez les les espèces africaines qui vont
donner homo sapiens moderne
donc c'est plutôt des poussées on va
dire des poussées et dès qu'ils ne sont
pas linéaires qui apparaissent de façon
convergente dans plusieurs lignes donc
alors ce qu'il faut savoir aussi à
propos du cerveau c'est qu'on a tendance
à résumer la taille du cerveau à
l'intelligence alors ça a tendance à
être vrai quand on compare des espèces
différentes donc quand on compare par
exemple un ba voila quand on compare à
un gorille à un humain et quand on
compare l'huma est plus intelligent et
un plus gros cerveau quand on pas
comparé à un gorille un rongeur le
gorille a tendance à être plus
intelligent que le rongeur est là un
plus gros cerveau donc voila c
il ya ça qui joue évidemment dans
l'intelligence la taille du cerveau
parce que évidemment plus on a un gros
cerveau plus on a deux neurones est plus
en plus en inde matière cérébrale pour
tourner pour gérer l'information mais la
taille du cerveau ne fait pas tout et
par exemple ici vous avez le compte du
nombre de neurones qui vous montrent
qu'en fait il ya dans dans mille 200 g
de cerveau humain il y a trois fois plus
de neurones que dans presque 3 kg de
cerveau d'éléphant voilà donc et ça
c'est important à prendre en compte
aussi s'est il n'y a pas que le nombre
n'y a pas que la quantité de matière
cérébrale qui compte il ya aussi le
câblage et j'ai envie de dire c'est pas
la taille qui compte c'est la façon dont
on s'en sert ben là on est exactement ça
c'est pas que la taille qui compte ya
aussi la façon dont ces câbles et et il
ya aussi eu aussi la région du cerveau
qui est qui et grosses parce que le
cerveau du de l'éléphant est
effectivement très gros mais le cerveau
a le plus grosse
ceret bel homme donc le plus gros
cervelet tout tout animal confondues or
le cervelet sa contrôler la locomotion
et pas l'intellect quoi ça n'a rien à
voir avec l'intelligence le cervelet
c'est la locomotion donc voilà c'est
tout ça s'est perdu
voilà tout ça s'est perdu niveau
intelligence c'est gagner ailleurs mais
c'est perdu niveau intelligence donc
voilà ça c'est assez important de à
prendre en compte
oui la taille du cerveau ça compte mais
pas que mais bon voilà comme on a que ça
de toute façon le registre fossile ne
nous donne que de la taille de cerveau
donc on ne sait pas comme s'il y avait
débat sur qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire et
qu'est-ce qu'on peut pas faire voilà
de toute façon on n'a que ça donc donc
ici vous avez le même schéma que je vous
ai montré tout à l'heure avec les
tailles de cerveau et je voulais me en
parallèle en fait de l'évolution des
techniques
est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant en fait
c'est de voir que l'évolution des
techniques n'est pas du tout en ligne
avec les ces augmentations du de la
taille de cerveau donc on a une première
augmentation de la taille de cerveau qui
je voulais dit arif chez homo habilis
homo erectus
or on avait déjà des outils il y à 3 3
millions d'années donc bien avant le
tout premier homo donc on avait déjà des
tout premiers outils l'industrie l'eau
mais que l'homme et quyen qui appareille
à 3,3 millions d'années et kinés qui du
coup n'est pas du tout en ligne avec
l'apparition des premiers homo ou du
premier pic d'augmentation de deux
tailles de cerveau et puis on a de
perfectionnement de cette technologie
donc la technologie c'est pas compliqué
ça se perfectionne en devenant plus
petits plus symétrique et plus fin voilà
donc le ldu valhall du baiia est plus
petit et un poil plus symétrique
donc c'est pas juste des cailloux péter
en deux pour dire les choses simplement
et le hall du vagin il appareille à 2,6
millions d'années c'est à dire après le
premier robot mais avant que la taille
du cerveau n'augmente
et puis vous avez lâchent les uns qui
appareille à 1 76 million d'années donc
à peu près à l'époque ou homo erectus
quitte le l'afrique pour l'asie et à
cette époque là c'est pareil on n'a pas
vraiment d'augmentation de taille de
cerveau
hop si on tourne à issy 1,5 million
d'années
voici à la limite voilà ça pourrait
corps et les plus ou moins ouais plus
assez plus de deux millions d'années
d'ailleurs up donc ça pourrait corrélés
éventuellement avec le premier pic
donc allez je vous accorde lâchent les
uns je vous accorde lâchent les uns qui
colle effectivement avec une
augmentation de taille de cerveau et
après vous avez l'invention du feu il ya
six ans milan et le middle stone age à
300 mille ans donc on peut aller
retourner là donc il ya cinq cent mille
six cent mille envoyée et il ya 200
milles en bon il ya des tailles de
cerveau qui augmente un tout petit peu
mais c'est pas le grand boom de
l'arrivée 2 finalement de sapiens et de
et des homos moderne on va dire donc
voilà c'est la corrélation ou pas est ce
que j'ai ce que j'essaie de vous montrer
ici c'est que la corrélation est pas
évidente évidente avec la taille du
cerveau voilà donc oui il y à un
perfectionnement de la technologie avec
la domestication du feu il ya six ans
milan
on parle bien de domestication du feu il
ya six ans milan parce que les premières
traces de feux contrôlés date d'il ya 2
5 millions d'années donc c'est pareil
2,5 millions d'années et dans une grotte
qu'on savait fréquenté par part entre
opus pas part aux maux du mois il y
aurait possiblement de l'omo mais
comparer ou à la quantité de parents
trop qu'on a retrouvés dans cette grotte
là la présence d' homo est plutôt
anecdotique donc encore une fois
l'évolution des technologies à la l'air
de suivre grosso merdo la l'évolution
des de la taille du cerveau mais pas que
voilà c'est ça si je veux bien vous
convaincre d'une chose avec ça c'est que
la taille du cerveau c'est pas tout
voilà et du coup ça complexe ça
complexifie un peu ça complique le
schéma classique on va dire des grandes
progression linéaire et puis de toute
façon enfin il suffit de regarder les
technologies modernes pour vous
convaincre qui a pas besoin d'une
augmentation de la taille du cerveau
pour avoir un pour avoir une
augmentation de la fin une une
amélioration de la technologie à progrès
de la technologie considérable les 50
dernières années
l'humain a pas évolué tant que ça ces
cinquante dernières années et puis à la
technologie elle par contre elle a pris
un boost 1 donc voilà il faut croire que
faut croire que même si ultime en
développer des technologies complexes
requiert un gros cerveau ça enfin
requiert un cerveau performant ça ça n'a
pas toujours été une condition
sinequanone et oui je tenais à rappeler
ici d'ailleurs qu' il ya une donc on
sait que l'humain façonne son
environnement
évidemment et en fait on a tendance à
attribuer sa à l'humain et alluma
uniquement mais l'être humain n'est pas
le seul à façonner son environnement et
à utiliser le feu notamment pour
façonner son environnement il y a aussi
les rapaces il y à des rapaces africains
et australiens qui
sont capables en fait durant un feu de
brousse de prendre des brindilles
enflammés et de les transporter dans une
autre dans une autre savane pour [ __ ]
le feu à cette savane et dans la raison
c'est probablement parce que pendant les
feux en fait les herbivores panique et
se mettent à s'enfuir tous azimuts et ça
ça leur permet du coup de com les
chasseurs qui qui envoie de la fumée
dans les terriers des de leurs proies
ça permet de les fumer en dehors de
leurs d en fumée en dehors de leur
terrier et de les capturer voilà du coup
quand ils foutent le feu comme ça c'est
de ces rapaces sont capables du coup de
chasse est beaucoup plus efficacement
donc l'être humain n'est pas le seul
finalement à modifier son à utiliser le
feu pour modifier son environnement et
et tout ça ça encore une fois ça va ça
vous montre que la taille du cerveau
c'est pas tout et que et qu'il ya
beaucoup de comportements qu'on dit être
typiquement humain alors qu'ils ne sont
pas finalement si typiquement humain que
ça voilà alors puisqu'on en est du coup
à parler de l'intelligence humaine et
moi on va parler de la culture et
notamment du début de la diversité
culturelle et ce début de la diversité
culturelle il apparaît avec le midol
stone age alors ce qu'on appelle le
middle stone age en afrique ça commence
il ya trois cent mille ans et ça finit à
25 mille ans alors je sais que l'âge de
pierre moyen en europe à des dates
complètement différente je sais même pas
s'il ya un équivalent d'ailleurs à l'âge
de pierre moyen en europe mais bref
voilà c'est les combles
comment dire les les technologies de
pierre en fait sont complètement
non synchrone entre les continents
généralement parce que les innovations
viennent d'afrique et après se répandent
dans le reste du monde
à cette époque donc voila et les
premiers à innover du coup ce sont les
africains au middle stone age donc il ya
trois cent mille ans c'est le début de
la diversité culturelle qui reflèterait
aussi le début de la modernité
cognitives quoi que cela veuille dire
voilà donc une certaine moderne une
certaine modernité cognitives ça
voudrait dire en gros un cerveau qui
commence à devenir câblées comme le
nôtre voilà et ça sent qu'on ne voit
d'ailleurs d'augmentation de taille du
cerveau donc on a une révolution une
genre de révolution culturelle ou d'un
seul coup on passe d'un ashley a
d'un ashley à universel à un middle
stone age où chaque partie d'afrique va
produire des outils différents
donc c'est ça le début de la diversité
culturelle chaque partie d'afrique va
produire des outils différents et en
afrique du sud on va même commencé à
produire des choses qui ne sont pas des
outils on va commencer à produire de
l'art donc il ya 80 mille ans par
exemple ont été retrouvés ce petit bout
d'os cre qui a été gravé avec ses
pattern géométriques
ce petit bout d'os cre ne servait à rien
on se met à faire des trucs qui servent
à rien et m un effort pour faire quelque
chose qui sert à rien ça s'appelle
dollar donc on commence à pratiquer
l'art pas encore l'art rupestre
mais on commence à graver des trucs
juste pour le plaisir de graver des
trucs et on commence à faire des trous
dans les coquillages
il ya 80 milan bat pour ce faire des
pour ce faire des parures qui ne servent
à rien à part à se faire beau donc voila
et et on aurait possiblement d'autres
preuves de la pratique de l'art avec
cette petite ce coquillage da balonne
qui date d'il ya cent mille ans et dans
lequel on a retrouvé encore une fois de
locre donc locre été contenue dans le
coquillage d'abalo et devait servir à
faire des peintures alors peut-être à
peindre le corps et ça ça s'est un peu
plus controversé parce que il est
possible que l'offre était étalée sur le
corps simplement pour repousser les
moustiques donc donc donc c'est pas
forcément une preuve d'armé en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il ya au moins
80 mille ans on commence à faire on
commence à mettre beaucoup d'efforts à
produire des trucs qui servent à rien et
ça c'est le début de l'art et ça c'est
le début de justement de la modernité
cognitif c'est le début d'un recâblage
du cerveau vers une modernité culturelle
voilà et alors les premières peintures
rupestres
d'afrique date d'il y à 24 milles ans
qui est plutôt bizarre en fait dans la
mesure où la grotte de lascaux enfin la
grotte de lascaux à quinze mille ans
donc non ça va mais mêlée on a des
peintures rupestres qui date de
de 37 mille ans donc à la grotte de la
grotte chauvet donc en france et on a
des peintures qui sont je crois à peu
près aussi vieille mais qui viennent
d'australie
donc c'est marrant qu'on aurait c'est
marrant de se dire qu'on aurait acquis
une modernité culturelle il ya 80 mille
ans pour au final avoir les premières
peintures rupestres à l'extérieur
d'afrique donc soit on n'a pas encore
découvert les peintures rupestres
africaine qui date d'il ya entre 80000
et 40000 en soit la peinture rupestre a
évolué de façon enfin est apparu de
façon convergente en europe et en
australie puis après en afrique
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas donc voilà
l'épreuve de modernité culturelle
d'abord donc comme je disais en afrique
avec justement la cale blond bosquet
ix20 ce qu'ils sont c'est ce que je vous
ai montré tout à l'heure les restes 10 à
80 mille ans vous avez dit plouffe qui
procède aussi des épreuves de modernité
culturelle à 60 mille ans mais après
vous avez des preuves
voilà vous avez des parures de
néandertaliens qui sont vous avez des
parures de néandertaliens qui ont
quarante mille ans et qui sont aussi qui
montre que la modernité culturelle peut
évoluer de façon complètement
convergentes à la fois chez homo sapiens
et chez d'autres espèces comme homo
neandertalensis et je fais partie de ces
gens qui appellent homo neandertalensis
homo neandertalensis et pas sapiens
neanderthalensis et je trouve que le
débat faut-il appeler néandertal sapiens
neanderthalensis ou neandertalensis
complètement stérile c'est de la
taxonomie je m'en fous mais alors
tellement je m'en fous mais alors
complètement mais on reparlera de ce
débat quand on parlera d'eux
des hybridations parce que évidemment
j'ai j'ai un passage de secours sur les
hybridations donc voila et puis on à
l'apparition de la pêche avec les
premières pompes il ya 80 mille ans au
congo et on allait les premières traces
de calcul aussi au congo il ya 21 milan
sur le site d'ishango donc le site
d'ishango qui n'est hélas pas sur cette
carte mais bon c'est au congo sa dette
il ya 21 mille ans les premières voilà
le pr baguette osseuse avec quelques
marques mais qui est des marques qui ne
sont pas disposées aléatoirement qui
sont disposés de telle façon qu'elles
ont l'air de forme et on va dire un
système numérique
voilà donc la première trace de calcul
donc maintenant on va s'arrêter
totalement de parler des autres
hominidés qu'homo sapiens on va
focaliser totalement sûr homo sapiens on
est à peu près à la moitié du cours
donc si vous voulez prendre un café et
fumer une clope comme d'habitude un jeu
ne vous encourage pas fumer mais de
toute façon je peux pas vous en empêcher
de là où je suis
donc voilà c'est le moment c'est le
moment de la pop aux de mettre en pause
la vidéo et on attaque l'origine et
l'évolution d'homo sapiens alors déjà
déjà homo sapiens dans sa forme
anatomiquement modernes il apparaît il y
a deux cent mille ans donc ce qu'on
appelle la forme anatomiquement modernes
c'est la forme comme comme vous le voyez
là donc l'humain moderne avec une face
complètement plate disparition totale du
bourrelet sus orbitaire qui est
recouvert par le feront donc le lobe
frontal du cerveau qui se développe
fortement vers l'avant et qui pousse du
coup le front par dessus le bourrelet
sus orbitaire pour les suces orbitaire
qui est bien présent chez l'homme de
néandertal donc même si on a un cerveau
qui est à peu près de la même taille
entre homo sapiens et le l'homme de
néandertal on a quand même une forme de
cerveau qui est différente avec un
cerveau globulaires avec un fort lobe
frontal chez homo sapiens alors qu'il y
en a une forme plutôt ovale chez
néandertal avec un fort chignon
occipital donc possiblement une zone de
laves eu l'air corticale de la vue plus
développée chez néandertal les dents
sont plus grosse que celle et chez les
humains non sapiens que chez sapiens
sapiens a vraiment une dentition très
réduite
donc il pousse à fond la tendance à la
réduction de la dentition chez homo et
un caractère éminemment sapiens c'est la
présence du petit menton le petit menton
qui est absent chez toutes les autres
espèces de du genre homo même homo
neandertalensis donc voyez que là on a
un manteau qui est fuyant qui part vers
l'arrière comme ça fou qui est brossé
vers l'arrière alors que là il ya un
petit menton une petite protubérance ici
qui est très très typique de homo
sapiens donc voilà bon je vous montre
vite fait le registre fossile de
néandertal parce que je vais pas y
passer la journée sur des en der talent
évidemment c'est le groupe frère
néandertal c'est le groupe frère de
sapiens donc évidemment c'est
intéressant de comparer sapiens et
néandertal comme je lé fais sur la diapo
précédente
mais après néandertal c'est un groupe
donc qui ces diverses qui a divergé de
homo sapiens
il ya donc au moins 400 mille ans voire
plus long plus longtemps donc les
premiers prêts néandertaliens son
dates à peu près de 2 600 mille ans et
on les retrouve du coup en espagne
notamment
notamment du côté de la cimade et los
masos qui vous étaient représentés tout
à l'heure avec sur la carte des homo
erectus donc il est possible que les
prêts néandertaliens dérivés eux-mêmes
d'homo erectus européen
et puis bah après ces prêts à
néanderthal ya donc qui ont déjà des
caractères de néandertal ont donné le
néanderthal canonique il y a quatre cent
mille ans donc le néanderthal canonique
c'est celui qu'on retrouve dans la
vallée néant d'air qu'on retrouve en
france voilà aussi de la ferrassie etc
mais on a des restes on a quand même des
restes de
domo en france qui pourrait remonter
jusqu'à un bon million d'années voire
plus mais il s'agit que d'outils en fait
donc c'est pas sûr si c'était de l'homo
erectus ou six étaient déjà en voie de
néandertal isation on va dire donc
est-ce qu'il va distinguer néandertal
d'homo sapiens ça va être
essentiellement la position du foramen
infra orbitaire donc chez néandertal le
foramen infra orbitaire et et pas
positionné au même endroit que chez homo
sapiens et il va y avoir cette petite
encoche aussi derrière la troisième
molaire inférieur il va y avoir une
petite encoche entre le bras montant de
la mandibule et la dernière molaires
donc ce petit vide là que vous voyez
c'est très typique de néandertal voyez
ici aussi pouf vous avez le bras montant
de la mandibule un une petite un petit
creux et la troisième molaire ça c'est
très typique de néandertal et donc homo
sapiens et néandertal ils ont un ancêtre
commun ils ont un ancêtre en commun qui
devait vivre il ya de cela six cent
mille ans et il ya des candidats
potentiels à cet ancêtre en commun alors
je vous ai parlé évidemment des homo
erectus qui vivait qui vivait en europe
mais c'est pas tellement sûr en fait que
les homo erectus d'europe ont donné
naissance à néanderthal il est fort
probable en fait que les néandertaliens
que l'école et néandertal d'europe et
plus descendre aussi d'une population
africaine
et en fait tout ce débat enfin tous tous
est parti en fait de la recherche est
extrêmement confus dû à un problème de
taxonomie qui est que en fait on a
tendance à appeler les homo sapiens
archaïque donc les homo sapiens dans
leur forme
anatomiquement archaïque qu'on oppose
homo sapiens sous leur forme
anatomiquement modernes on l'est on a
tendance à les appeler homo
heidelbergensis et les hommes et les
prêts néandertaliens on a aussi tendance
à les appeler homo heidelbergensis donc
donc ça vous donne qu'en fait il y a
deux scénarios possibles soit soit on a
une espèce qui s'appelle homo
heidelbergensis qui est apparue
supposément en afrique à partir d' homo
ergaster et qui s'est dispersé en europe
pour donner aux néandertal et qui est et
dont une partie est restée en afrique
pour donner homo sapiens ou alors ou
alors au moins et d'albert gagnent 6
c'est un taxon poubelles dans lequel on
range à peu près tout ce qui est trop
dérivé pour être homo erectus mais tout
ce qui est pas à ses dérivés encore pour
être appelé homo sapiens et néandertal
et dans ce cas là ça veut dire que les
homo erectus européen ont pu évoluer sur
place
devenir ce qu'on appelle des homo
heidelbergensis avant de devenir des
hommes de néandertal en europe et que en
amérique en afrique les homo ergaster
ont évolué et donner des homo
heidelbergensis ou des trucs qu'on
appelait au moyen de berriane si c'est
qu'on appelle aux suites homo sapiens et
donc ça ça ne nous aide pas du tout
voilà le là il ya un imbroglio
taxonomique qui rend les choses pas
clair du tout et et encore je vous fais
la version simplifiée puisque homo et de
certains homo heidelbergensis en afrique
sont appelés au mot rhodésienne 6
d'autres homo heidelbergensis sont
appelés au mot et demi et caen n'est
qu'en europe on a aussi homo antecessor
qui serait donc un prêt néandertaliens
aussi voilà donc tout ça c'est
possiblement la même espèce ou
possiblement pas du tout la même espèce
et puis bon je vous laisse vous
brouillés donc homo heidelbergensis
alors on le retrouve aussi bien en
afrique qu'en europe
du coup entre 600 milles et 200 mille
ans c'est écrit sur la diapo uniquement
europe mais le crâne que je vous montre
la été retrouvé à florice bat c'est à
dire en afrique du sud de 100 ou 200 km
au nord de bloemfontein donc c'est homo
heidelbergensis est éminemment africains
aussi un donc on le retrouve entre 600
milles et 200 mille ans en europe au mot
et de et en afrique
homo heidelbergensis a priori les
chinois commencerait aussi à trouver de
l'homo heidelbergensis donc est-ce qu'on
serait encore sur une troisième
évolution convergente de la morphologie
et d'albert yens 6 on sait pas où est ce
qu'on serait encore une fois sur une
dispersion à partir d'une population
commune et donc homo heidelbergensis bas
il a les traits de l'homo sapiens
archaïque à savoir à savoir tout comme
un homo sapiens mais avec des gros bourg
les sursauts orbitaire et un front
fuyant voilà et des naseaux plus large
aussi comme vous pouvez voir ce qui ce
qui fait penser un peu à néanderthal et
donc est par exemple tenez un très bon
exemple c'est l'exemple de l'homo
sapiens dit moderne qui a été trouvé à
jebel est rude au maroc et qui serait et
qui serait daté donc de 300 mille ans
donc on est complètement dans la gamme
de
de d'apparition dans la gamme de vie de
michael berg n 6 et donc est donc ce cet
individu a été appelée homo sapiens
anatomiquement modernes dans la
littérature alors que vous pouvez voir
qu'il a quand même un petit museau bien
sympa je veux dire il a un bon petit
museau il a pas de menton il a un crâne
qui est quand même relativement robuste
de manière générale avec des bombes ou
relais sur son orbite ra front
légèrement fuyant pas totalement voyez
un crâne le front est légèrement fuyant
il n'est pas verte ical
comme il n'est censé l'être chez homo
sapiens le la boîte crânienne est
définitivement plus globulaires avec un
bon chignon à l'arrière deux niveaux de
l'occiput donc ouais voilà voilà où on
disons que non seulement le problème
taxonomique d'heidelberg haine de la
transition entre elles de halberg m6 et
sapiens et confus mais en plus la
littérature mais la littérature récente
n'a pas l'air de vouloir simplifier le
problème parce que voilà si ça c'est du
monde
si ça c'est du homo sapiens dans sa
forme moderne
je veux dire où va-t-on où va-t-on nan
ça à la limite ça aurait dû être
rappelés au modèle berg n 6 enfin ça
aurait pu être appelé homo
heidelbergensis ça aurait peut-être dû
être appelée homo sapiens archaïque mais
homo sapiens sous sa forme
anatomiquement modernes
c'est enfin moi en tout cas quand je
quand je dis ça mais étudiants cette
chose a été appelée homo sapiens
anatomiquement modernes mais et une
heure me regarde avec des yeux gros
comme ça en me demandant mais tu vas
essayer d'être cohérent un peu oui ou
pas tu vois ce que je veux dire bah oui
je n'y peux rien c'est la littérature
est ainsi fait
e voilà c'est comme ça que ça a été
publiée en tout cas donc mais en tout
cas quoi qu'il arrive on se retrouve
avec une carte à peu près de cette façon
donc on est là je vous là on est à peu
près il ya
deux cents 200 mille ans donc et ya 100
à 200 mille ans donc on à homo sapiens
sous sa forme
anatomiquement modernes et archaïque
confondues bond normalement il ya deux
cent mille ans n'y a plus vraiment de il
ya plus beaucoup de homo sapiens
archaïque donc mais voilà un sens de
cent mille ans on à homo sapiens donc en
afrique archaïque et modèles anatomiques
modernes
on a des prêts et néandertaliens slash
néandertaliens en europe et on a encore
des erectus et possiblement des ailes de
l'urga nsis du coup comme je disais en
asie donc voila voila le monde tel qu'il
est distribuée entre les espèces
d'hominidés il y à entre 100 et 200
mille ans donc c'est à partir de ça
qu'on va qu'on va démarrer parce qu'il
faut arrêter de rajouter de complexifier
de l'histoire mais voilà un petit résumé
graphique pour vous montrer parce qu'en
plus de choses que je n'ai pas précisé
mais aubenas lady entre 100 et 200 mille
ans il est là évidemment je vous ai pas
dit évidemment
évidemment je vous ai pas dit mais aux
monnaies les 10 il est là et je pourrais
éventuellement parler des ancêtres de
denisova qui devait se trouver par là
aussi
donc bon bref donc il ya au modèle et
dia entre 100 et 200 mille ans donc il
ya quelques millions d'années on avait
il ya deux millions d'années on avait
encore au loin habilis qui a fini par
disparaître on a eu donc homo erectus
qui est parti en asie et qui a donné
donc homo erectus l'homme de java
l'homme de pékin et qui sur la fin va
donner l'homme de florès il ya cinquante
mille ans et on devrait même rajouté au
mot lui sonne n 6 du coup même si on n'a
pas
même si apparemment on n'a pas tellement
de très très bonnes dates pour homo
lucio et m6 mais là je vous renvoie à ma
vidéo sur au modus oden 6 on en a
discuté en long en large et en travers
déjà deux homos luçonnais 6 donc bref
voilà homo erectus qui donc fini par
donner des espèces insulaires qui vont
survivre
plus récemment que les plus récents des
homo erectus et puis vous avez l'autre
branche possiblement ergaster qui va
donner homo heidelbergensis slash homo
rhodésienne 6 slash tout un tas de
bordel mais bon on va les appeler au
maire de bergues m6 qui va donner homo
sapiens d'abord arcade d'abord sous sa
forme archaïque puis sa forme moderne et
qui va donner en allant en europe
possiblement au moins et d'albert
gagnent 6 au moment et c'est sort enfin
les prêts néandertaliens en gros qui
vont devenir les néandertaliens donc
voila et donc vous avez la possibilité
que ce soit des homo erectus locaux qui
est donnée d homo erectus qui ont évolué
localement en europe qui en fait nos
données les néandertaliens donc il
pourrait y avoir une flèche en fait
juste ici et voilà et donc tout le débat
voilà tout le débat sur faut-il appeler
néandertal n 6 ou sapiens
neanderthalensis staub est là bas il
tient aussi un peu du débat qui a entre
d'où vient d'où viennent les prêts
néandertaliens en fait un ace qui
viennent des aides holberg m6 d'afrique
ou est ce qu ils viennent d erectus
déjà là donc moi ici l'hypothèse que
j'ai retenu c'est les aides albert
gagnent 6 d'afrique parce que parce que
si on nomme des espèces c'est pas pour
le sais pas pour le décorum normalement
c'est pour être pour essayer d'être
cohérent et de refléter une certaine
idée de la phylogénie mais bon voilà
vous aurez compris que c'est pas que
c'est pas tout à fait gagné tout cela
n'ayant servi qu'à introduire finalement
l'origine légèrement confus d'homo
sapiens donc une origine d'homo sapiens
parmi homo heidelbergensis sachant que
génétiquement parlant c'est parce qu'en
plus il ya les analyses génétiques qui
ont été faites et qui montre que homo
sapiens est censé être le groupe frère
de néandertal mais comme on n'a pas
encore vraiment de gênes d'heidelberg m6
ça pose problème et on a des gènes par
contre dans tc sort donc les hanter les
homos antécécent heures qui viennent de
la cimade et los masos qui sont censés
être des prêts néandertaliens sauf que
leurs gènes semble indiquer qu'ils sont
plus proches parents de denisot va donc
voilà donc c'était juste pour vous
introduire à la confusion taxonomique
qui règne au sein de l'origine même du
genre en fin de l'espèce homo sapiens
donc c'est juste pour dire que on est
très très loin d'être fixé sur l'origine
d'homo sapiens voilà et sur l'origine de
néandertal et sur l'origine de toutes
ces espèces qu'on appelle les les hommes
dérivés voilà les late homo sapiens les
late homos voilà un dernier truc dont je
vais vous faire cadeau avant qu'on passe
purement et simplement à homo sapiens
c'est le petit ips pour arriver à
différencier les crânes de ces trois
différentes espèces donc le petit ips
c'est de regarder les yeux les yeux de
heidelberg m6 sont colère voyez que les
orbites les deux bourrelets sur ce
orbitaire convergent au niveau du nez et
donne l'impression qu'en fait il n'est
pas content et d'albert gagnent 6 donc
par exemple donc ça c'est le crâne de
kaboul qui vient de
qui vient du zimbabwe mais vous avez en
europe par exemple tautavel donc voilà
si vous allez voir le crâne de l'homme
de tautavel qui est un prêt
néandertaliens et d'albert guen si c'est
bien il a les yeux colère très typique
de la dahlberg n 6 alors qu'à l'opposé
vous avez sapiens qui lui a les yeux
tristesse voilà oui quand on le regarde
il a l'air d'être tous tristes parce
qu'il a les orbites carrés qui penche un
petit peu sur les côtés comme ça et puis
l'homme de néandertal lui là les belles
orbite bien ronde est complètement
neutre voilà merci merci julien de nous
donner ces petites ips mais de rien donc
voilà colère triste neutre donc
maintenant on va s'attaquer purement et
simplement à l'origine d'homo sapiens
est alors l'origine d'homo sapiens ce
qui est bien c'est qu'il ya suffisamment
de mots sapiens qui reste aujourd'hui
pour qu'on n'est pas forcément besoin
des fossiles pour avoir déjà une bonne
idée de où ils viennent donc si on
regarde les gènes des homo sapiens
moderne et bien on constate qu'il y a
des que les diversité génétique d'homo
sapiens n'est pas complètement
aléatoires donc tout en haut de l'arbre
ici vous avez les américains ici vous
avez les populations asiatiques donc
asiatiques et normalement il doit y
avoir les européens en coin les
européens à ce faux poussé dans les
européens font partie de ce club là donc
ici vous avez les populations asiatiques
ici vous avez les populations
américaines donc un ancêtre commun qui
vous montrent qu'en fait l'ancêtre
commun des populations enfin que les
populations sont d'abord arrivés en asie
ouf une branche pouf de branche et que
ces populations sont ensuite dispersés
en amérique et c'est pour ça que les
américains sont tout en haut de l'arbre
c'est parce que le dernier continent
conquis par l'espèce humaine c'est
l'amérique
après avoir traversé le détroit de
béring durant le dernier âge glaciaire
là vous avez encore des alors ce ne sont
pas des asiatiques se sont les
indonésiens
mais bon faut passer par l'asie pour
arriver par là donc tout ça c'est de
l'asiatique et sur seclin de là vous
avez les
une bonne partie des populations arabes
et les européens et d'autres populations
arabes et vous avez des populations
africaines et ensuite vous avez des
populations africaines et vous avez des
populations africaines et vous avez
encore et toujours des populations
africaines notamment les
notamment les l'école san donc ce qu'on
appelle communément les bushmen et les
pygmées donc ils sont les derniers
chasseurs cueilleurs qui vivent encore
aujourd'hui et qui sont donc tout à la
base de l'arbre et ses populations
africaines tout à la base de l'arbre ne
veut pas dire qu'elles sont primitifs je
vous préviens que si je vois ça dans les
commentaires ça va chier ça veut pas
dire qu'ils sont primitifs ça veut dire
que l'arbre de
de l'évolution humaine sans racines très
profondément en afrique
voilà à partir de là déjà
l'arbre sans racines en afrique et là il
est encore plus profondément en afrique
et là on est carrément voilà avec
l'égoïsme et la centre et en afrique
centrale la pouf on est carrément
complètement en afrique donc l'origine
humaine
rien que par la génétique peut être
placé en afrique ce qui est évidemment
confirmé par le registre fossile mais
voilà la génétique déjà si vous niez
l'origine africaine de l'humanité faut
commencer à nier un sacré paquet de
gênes voilà donc ça c'est le premier
point
ensuite parce que vous dit cet arbre
c'est que il ya une dispersion qui va
avoir lieu d'abord au proche orient puis
en europe et en asie donc une dispersion
qui va s'effectuer par le vent voilà
donc le levant c'est la connexion qui a
entre l'afrique et l'asie quoi qui passe
par le moyen-orient
donc voilà rien que par cet arbre vous
pouvez d'ores et déjà dire dispersion en
amérique du nord
dispersion à partir d'une région mythe
web à partir d'une région à la bordure
de l'europe du moyen-orient et de l'asie
donc le dispersion à partir du levant et
origines profondément africaine ici et
ce juste à partir des gènes et voilà et
ça c'est la beauté de la génétique et
puis la baule autres beautés de la
génétique c'est qu'on peut allier
appliquée l'horloge moléculaire donc ça
c'est le même arbre mais en plus
en plus ce focus sur la racine de
l'arbre donc là on a mis tout ce qu'il
est et non africains c'est juste pour
réduit à ça voilà ce qui est vrai la
diversité des populations africaines est
extrêmement faible la diversité
génétique des populations non africaine
est extrêmement faible et ce n'est en
réalité qu'un tout petit extrait de
populeux de la diversité génétique des
populations est-africaine donc le gros
de la diversité génétique de la
diversité génétique des des populations
humaines se trouvent en afrique donc
l'afrique c'est vraiment le coeur de
l'évolution humaine et c'est toujours le
coeur évidemment de l'évolution humaine
et donc à partir de cette diversité
génétique donc sachant le temps qu'il
faut pour les mutations pour s'accumuler
on a calculé que cette que l'origine du
genre humain sous sa forme moderne
puisqu'il ne reste aujourd'hui que des
homo sapiens sous leur forme
anatomiquement modernes
c'est environ trois cent mille ans donc
ce qui est à peu près l'âge de
du crâne dirk food du crâne du maroc et
du crâne de floris bad qui sont
anatomiquement pas moderne
donc soit ces choses sont en réalité
anatomiquement modernes mais jusqu'où ça
se reflète pas vraiment sur leur
anatomie
soit on a un gap dans le registre
fossile
il reste encore à trouver l'humain
anatomiquement modernes qui aurait 300
milles en avance à la l'origine de homo
sapiens était plutôt placer environ 160
200 mille ans maximum donc là cette
étude génétique là est très récente
la découverte de ce crâne là est très
récente donc vous voyez que là on est
sur du on est sur des choses des données
qui sont en constante mutation
peut-être que dans peut-être que dans
deux ans l'idée que homo sapiens à 300
milles en homo sapiens moderne à 300
mille ans sera complètement botté en
touche
peut-être que peut-être qu'elle sera
confirmée on ne sait pas encore en tout
cas
quoi qu'il arrive si adam et eve
devaient être remplis santé représentait
d'une quelconque façon adam et eve
devait être noir puisqu'ils sont
éminemment africa et donc les précédents
résultats donc les précédentes datation
de
du genre en fin de l'espèce homo sapiens
et est basé essentiellement sur l'adn
mitochondrial est donc on avait
déterminé que lev mitochondrial avait
environ 120 mille ans ensuite on avait
rajouté d'autres gènes à ça et on avait
repoussé cette date à 160 milles en est
et puis après on a fait des datations
sur le chromosome y puisque le
chromosome y est à l'homme ce que la
mitochondrie est à la femme c'est à dire
de transmission purement patrilinéaire
alors que la mitochondrie est uniquement
matrilinéaire donc uniquement transmise
par la mer alors que le chromosome y
n'ait transmis ce club par les mâles est
en fait en faisant des datations sur ce
chromosome y ont à trouver des dates qui
allait de 140000 à 400 mille ans et ça
et du coup ça vous fait vous demander
mais comment ils ont fait pour se
rencontrer du coup lève mitochondrial
est là donc chromosome y
bah ils n'ont pas eu besoin de se
rencontrer voilà lève mitochondrial lève
mitochondrial comme je lé dinh était une
femme et c'est l'ancêtre commun de
toutes les mitochondries qu'on rencontre
aujourd'hui mais ce n'est l'ancêtre
commun que des mitochondries ça veut pas
dire que c'est d'ancêtres communs de
toutes les femmes d'aujourd'hui
attention et c'est ça qui est ça qui est
piégeux en fait c'est qu'il peut y avoir
des lignes et qui se sont complètement
éteinte et qui enfin il y avait un
ancêtre commun des femmes qui étaient
aussi d'ancêtres communs de toutes les
mitochondries d'aujourd'hui mais cet
ancêtre commun à ces états et lui il
aurait pu avoir
cent soixante mille deux cent mille
quatre cent mille ans aussi et c'est
pareil pour le chromosome y
c'est pas parce que on a d'ancêtres
communs à tous les chromosomes
d'aujourd'hui qui peut avoir vécu entre
140 mille quatre cent mille ans que
c'est forcément l'ancêtre commun des
hommes c'est juste d'ancêtres communs du
chromosome y
donc voilà là vous avez l'ancêtre commun
de tous les homos sapiens moderne et
vous voyez qu'en fait il n'y a pas
besoin que l'ancêtre commun des
chromosomes soit contemporain de lens
soit la même personne que l'ancêtre
commun des homo sapiens est ici vous
avez lève mitochondrial qui est aussi
l'ancêtre commun de toutes les deux
toutes les mitochondries humaine donc
dans bardon et ça c'est l'ancêtre commun
de tous les êtres humains modernes book
est ce que vous montre aussi ce schéma
c'est que lev mitochondrial n'a pas
besoin d'avoir vécu en même temps que le
la dans chromosomiques parce que encore
encore une fois voici l'ancêtre commun
de tous les humains mais voici l'ancêtre
des mitochondries et voici l'ancêtre des
chromosomes y donc c'est pas parce que
pas parce qu'ils n'ont pas vécu en même
temps qu'ils peuvent pas être les adam
et les élèves de respectifs de leurs
gènes
et encore une fois jean revient du coup
à ce que je vous disais sur le court sur
les chiroptères c'est que quand on fait
de la phylogénie génétiques ont fait de
la phylogénie enfin quand on fait de la
phylogénie ont fait de la phylogénie de
caractère et ça marche aussi pour les
fils au génie génétique si vous faites
de la phylogénie du chromosome y vous
faites de la phylogénie du chromosome y
est uniquement du chromosome y pas des
humains en général seulement du
chromosome y
et quand vous faites de la phylogénie
des humains basée sur les mitochondries
vous faites en fait de la phylogénie de
mitochondries pas de pas de la
phylogénie de tous les êtres humains et
c'est seulement à vous de décider encore
une fois après si vous pensez que cette
phylogénie représentatif d'une vraie
phylogénie et dans le cas de chromosome
y ait de mitochondries ça marche pas si
bien que ça voilà mais c'est intéressant
du coup de voir que que du coup le
finalement on n'aurait pas dû appeler ça
des historiques mans on a appelé ça lève
mitochondrial est là dans chromosome y
mais au final on n'aurait pas dû on
aurait juste pas dû voilà c'était
c'était trompeur et encore une fois donc
ça c'est juste une carte encore une fois
pour vous représenter la diversité
génétique des humains modernes
donc on attaque toujours pas le registre
fossile pour l'instant c'est juste la
diversité génétique des êtres humains
modernes et vous pouvez voir qu'en fait
la diversité génétique est très très
forte en afrique notamment en afrique
subsaharienne est qu en fait plus on
s'éloigne du berceau africain et pouf
plus la diversité génétique diminue
parce que les populations sont partis
avec un certain poule de diversité et se
sont répandus en abandonnant derrière
elle cette diversité
donc évidemment aujourd'hui la les
mouvements de populations ont tendance à
arreux mélanger un peu tout ça mais
historiquement c'est comme ça que ça
s'est produit et donc le l'origine
africaine de l'homme se reflètent
profondément sur leur diversité
génétique et cette carte là je trouve le
montre très bien évidemment on ne peut
pas faire à court de d'évolution humaine
en afrique du sud sans parler de
l'origine profonde des inégalités c'est
à dire la couleur de peau parce que la
couleur de peau alors autant c'est un
sujet délicat en afrique du sud
autant ils n'ont pas tous les tabous
qu'on peut avoir
en france par exemple sur le fait parler
de la couleur de peau des gens la
couleur de peau est vraiment un sujet
non tabou c'est un sujet qui reste
délicat parce qu'il a des implications
politiques et historiques très très
grande en afrique du sud je veux dire
tous au courant de l'apartheid mais
comme ça fait cent cinquante ans que le
pays tourne sur saisine égalise sur site
des inégalités basé sur des sur des sur
la couleur de peau
au final parler de couleur de peau c'est
pas un problème ça fait cent cinquante
ans qu'ils le font en fait de parler de
couleur de peau ça fait cent cinquante
ans que la société tourne là dessus en
fait donc ya pas il n'ya pas les tabous
en fait et donc alors ce qui est
intéressant avec l'évolution de la
couleur de peau c'est déjà de commencer
par les l'ancêtre commun du chimpanzé et
de l'homme qui devait avoir la peau
claire pour une simple et bonne raison
c'est que les chimpanzés ont la peau
claire puisqu'ils ont une du pelage donc
le pelage protège la peau et donc rendre
une peau sombre complètement
complètement inutile pour la simple et
bonne raison c'est que en fait la peau
sombre est directement file la couleur
sombre de la peau est directement
fonction de l'exposition au soleil
donc c'est vous pouvez voir ici la soul
est le degré d'insolation qui corrèle
complètement avec la couleur de peau
sur cette carte de répartition des
couleurs dépôt donc donc la peau sombre
est définitivement une peau adapté à eux
seuls un très fort ensoleillement
ça c'est déjà c'est le premier truc donc
les chimpanzés ils ont beau vivre en
région tropicale ils sont couverts d'un
pelage extrêmement foncez donc ils n'ont
pas besoin d'avoir une peau sombre
ils ont la peau claire puis on a la
perte des poils qui a lieu il y a
environ 1,2 million d'années donc qui a
lieu chez homo erectus ou homo ergaster
si on veut donc chez homo ergaster slash
erectus vous avez perte des poils qui a
été reconstituée donc grâce à un gène
qui contrôle justement là
la pousse des poils ou la perte des
poils et donc on a constaté une mutation
de ce gène qui que par horloge
moléculaire a l'air de s'être produite
il y à 1,2 million d'années mais après
il faut savoir que il ya aussi
l'évolution des puces et des poux enfin
pas des puces et des poux des morpions
et des poux qui nous donne un indice
aussi sur l'évolution de la pilosité
notamment les morpions et les poux sont
affalés comment dire donc pour qu'il y
ait des morpions et des poux pour que
les morpions et des poux soit deux
espèces différentes
il faut qu'il y est il faut qu'il y ait
séparation du coup entre la chevelure
est l'endroit où on trouve les morpions
c'est à dire le pubis et donc à partir
de cette hypothèse là on peut en déduire
que l'ip que la divergence entre le
morpion que l'apparition du morpion
humain qui est d'ailleurs dérivé du
morpion du gorille et non pas du tout
humain d'ailleurs mais voilà
l'apparition du morpion humain n'a pu se
faire que quand il y avait une zone
pubienne séparer de la zone de la
pilosité
[Musique]
capillaire donc donc donc et ça ça date
d'il ya à peu près 3 millions d'années
donc il y avait déjà un début de
séparation finalement entre les zones la
zone la pilosité pubienne et la pilosité
capillaire qui a commencé il ya trois
millions d'années avec les
australopithèques très probablement puis
une perte complète des poils il y à 1,2
million d'années chez père gaster slash
erectus probablement en afrique et c'est
là et seulement et donc pendant ces 2
millions d'années qui ont séparé ces
deux événements ya pu y avoir
assombrissement de la peau au fur et à
mesure au fur et à mesure de la perte
des poils au final donc à partir du 1,2
million d'années on est à peu près sûr
que du coup la peau est devenu sombre
chez tous les hommes chez tous les
hominidés parce que tous les hominidés
vivaient en milieu tropical à l'époque à
part peut-être les homo erectus d'asie
qui vivait au point le plus au nord mais
voilà les hominidés d'afrique homo
ergaster et inclut les ancêtres des
humains modernes devait avoir la peau
sombre et puis arrive du coup néandertal
donc qui diverge de des humains et
néandertal il va à la conquête de
l'europe est là bas on se pèle les
meules et il sait pas très ensoleillée
donc on a une évolution des gènes de la
couleur de la peau et la peau
s'éclaircit donc chez néandertal donc
néandertal avaient la peau claire et les
cheveux blonds et les yeux bleus
comme une adaptation à la c'était une
adaptation à la finalement à la perte de
luminosité donc pour absorber plus de
vide
enfin pour absorber plus de rayonnement
solaire qui permettent de synthétiser la
vitamine d parce que quand vous avez la
peau noire et qui fait pas beaucoup de
soleil vous synthétiser pas des masses
de vitamine d et vous en avez besoin
pour construire des os solides et dieu
sait que néandertal avec des os solides
et puis dans la lignée humaine il ya est
dans la lignée humaine en fait il va y
avoir deux événements parallèles à
premier événement donc chez l'ancêtre
des populations européennes qui va ré
évolué qui va évoluer une seconde fois
une peau plus claire donc c'est le même
gène que chez néandertal qui va évoluer
une seconde fois et il ya une partie
aussi des gènes qui vont être hérité
directement de néandertal à homo sapiens
puisque je vous rappelle que ils se sont
ils se sont libres idées et donc ça ça a
lieu alors ça a pu commencer
déjà il ya quarante mille ans donc quand
on est en d'herta les homo sapiens ont
commencé à s'hybrider mais sinon la peau
n'est réellement devenu très clair que
healy à 800 qui lie à 8000 ans donc chez
homo sapiens la peau n'est devenu
vraiment blanche en europe que healy à
8000 ans donc huit mille ans ça veut
dire que le premier humain qui a posé le
pied
enfin ça veut dire que les premiers
humains qui sont arrivés en europe
devaient être noir et maintenant on a
même récemment une analyse génétique qui
est pas encore publiées mais qui a été
mais dont les résultats ont déjà été
annoncés et qui apparemment a trouvé que
le premier humain à atteindre les îles
anglaises donc l'homme de che d'art qui
a vécu il ya 5000 ans avait la peau
noire
donc on repousserait même encore plus
encore plus près de nous donc encore
plus récemment l'origine de la peau
blanche
dans ce cas là donc et ça c'est une
reconstitution faciale de l'homme de
cheddar avec des cheveux noirs et crépus
et la peau éminemment noir donc
il est fort possible que enfin il ya
encore beaucoup à découvrir sur
l'évolution de la peau claire chez chez
les ch et homo sapiens européen mais
c'est en quoi qu'il arrive c'est un
événement très très récent homo sapiens
et et noir à la base et aîné devenu
blanc que bien plus tard et il ya un
autre truc qu'on sait c'est qu'il ya
cinq cent mille ans au moins deux
libériennes 6 il ya un gène qui a qui a
paru chez homo heidelbergensis et qui a
rendu la peau encore plus sombre chez
nos ancêtres donc donc la peau claire a
évolué très récemment
mais ça veut pas dire que la peau sombre
n'a pas continué d'évoluer de son côté
voilà donc la avoir une peau sombre
c'est pas seulement faut pas considérer
que la peau sombre est à caractère
primitif
loin de là avoir la peau sombre c'est
aussi un caractère évolué c'est aussi
une adaptation une adaptation à
l'ensoleillement donc c'est pas parce
que les faut pas prendre ce que nous a
dit que cette étude qui a été faite
qu'il ya découvert que les voeux que la
peau encore plus sombre était elle est
même apparue il ya cinq cent mille ans
ça nous montre que même la peau sombre
est une n'est pas un caractère qu'on
devrait considérer comme plaisir morphx
et un caractère qui évolue aussi et qui
continue de changer
donc voilà le l'être humain est
constamment en train d'évoluer
la peau n'est qu'un des multiples
caractère la couleur de la peau n'est
qu'un des multiples caractère qui évolue
constamment dernière partie de secours
l'histoire de l'homme en dehors de
l'afrique
donc on a déjà vu que homo erectus a
commencé à quitter l'afrique entre 2,1
et 1,8 million d'années avec les plus
anciens homo erectus retrouver à demain
ici mais quelques outils retrouvés il ya
2,1 millions d'années en chine
et tenez je vous parlais tout à l'heure
de
de la cimade et los masos des ath et de
atapuerca bah voila c'est par là qu'a
été retrouvée homo antecessor donc c'est
par là que le bordel taxonomique
delberghe n 6 la chanter ses sorts et le
plus est avec des gènes de denisot va
aussi se trouve le plus de façons le
plus aigu bon mais homo sapiens on est
là pour parler d' homo sapiens alors
restons simples homo sapiens sort
d'afrique
il y à entre 200 et 100 mille ans une
première fois
parce qu'en réalité homo sapiens va
sortir deux fois d'afrique donc la
première tentative de sortie d'afrique
d'homo sapiens elle a lieu entre deux
semblent entre 200000 et cent mille ans
et donc les preuves de sa sortie
d'afrique sont devant vous vous avez ici
donc cette mâchoire qui provient de ce
qui est aujourd'hui l'israël et qui est
vieille de cent quatre-vingt mille ans
qui est définitivement la dentition d'un
homo sapiens il n'y a pas de doute là
dessus c'est c'est pas du ça c'est pas
la morphologie dentaire d'un erectus ou
d'un néandertal définitivement les
prémolaires notamment sont beaucoup trop
grasse il pourrait être autre chose que
du sapiens la troisième molaire vous
pouvez voir est plus petite que la
deuxième molaires ce qui est aussi un
caractère qui fait beaucoup penser à
sapiens et puis il ya cent mille ans
enfin il ya 90 mille ans toujours en
israël donc dans le on est dans la
région du levant c'est à dire les
premiers sapiens qui sortent qui font
leur poussée en dehors d'afrique donc
ses premiers on a un premier crâne dans
cette sépulture qui a été trouvée donc
ça coïncide d'ailleurs avec la première
sépulture
une des premières sépultures attribué à
sapiens l'autre étant plus controversé
est vieille de trois cent mille ans mais
voilà là vous voyez la face plate
l'absence de boulet sur orbite r le
front bien droit donc là il n'y a pas de
doute et le crâne bien globuleux s'il
n'y a pas de doute sur le fait que ça
c'est du beau du vrai du sapiens
voilà donc il ya entre 100000 les deux
cent mille ans première poussée de sa
pièce en dehors d'afrique poussé en
dehors d'afrique qui est aussi soutenu
par les données génétiques dont je
reparlerai un petit peu après donc là ce
que je vais vous montrer c'est justement
le fait qu'il y à deux pouces et en
dehors d'afrique la première qui a lieu
entre 100000 et 200 mille ans et qui est
ici représentée en blanc bon les dates
sont pas exactement les mêmes que celles
que je vous donne mais ça a été révisée
encore récemment c'est pour ça je vous
donne les dates révisé donc entre 100000
et 200 mille ans on a une première
poussée qui qui sort d'afrique qui est
cette ligne blanche et qui atteint
jusqu'à l'asie en fait et qui qui
atteint l'asie il ya à peu près 80 mille
ans et cette première poussée en fait va
complètement s'éteindre et elle va
complètement s'éteindre pour deux
raisons d'une changement climatique et
de deux le fait que néandertal à la même
époque va aussi se balader hors d'europe
et va atteindre aussi cette même région
il ya entre 100000 et 200 mille ans et
du coup homo sapiens va côtoyer
néandertal est en fait ils vont rentrer
en concurrence et homo sapiens va perdre
et oui la première poussée hors
d'afrique d'homo sapiens sapiens s'est
retrouvé confronté à néandertal et
sapiens a perdu donc sapiens et
remballer ses gaules est reparti en
afrique
enfin je dis ça comme ça mais en réalité
le il a rien remballer du tout il s'est
éteint en asie un point c'est tout il a
rien remballer du tout donc sa place à
continuer d'exister en asie entre 100000
et 80 mille ans en ce pardon sapiens a
continué d'exister en afrique
pardon entre 100000 et 80 mille ans mais
a complètement disparu d'asie pendant
cette époque là parce que il a perdu en
fait contre eux néandertal et puis
certainement aussi s'est il retrouvé
confronté un homo erectus de ce côté là
est pareil c'est pas et s'est pas senti
à son aise
et puis il ya eu aussi ce changement
climatique
qui est passée par là parce que
évidemment les dispersions de sapiens en
dehors d'afrique sont sont très
étroitement contrôlée par le climat
c'est à dire que sapiens il peut pas
changer il peut pas sortir d'african
apens n'importe quand quand c'est une
période glaciaire sapiens il est un peu
coincé parce qu'en fait le
voilà le sahara qui vient très récemment
de se former le l'apparition du sahara
est très très très récente
rappelez-vous commis aux scènes y avait
une jungle il y avait ça il entre aux
puces donc il y avait une jungle à cet
endroit là il y avait le lac tchad qui
étaient énormes dans lequel on retrouve
une faune très diverses et puis ba2 et
puis quelque part au pléistocène maboul
le sahara il se forme et donc toute
cette zone sarid hi-fi et donc pendant
les périodes glaciaires et l'humidité se
retrouvent stockés au niveau des pôles
et au niveau des glaciers et c'est le
climat global sarid hi-fi et donc le
sahara est à son maximum d'extension est
homo sapiens se retrouve coincé en
afrique subsaharienne et peu de pourquoi
pas un petit peu au nord de l'afrique
éventuellement mais pendant les périodes
interglaciaires le climat redevient un
peu plus chaud et surtout redevient plus
humide et du coup là il ya des bandes de
savane qui permettent à sapiens de
migrer en dehors d'afrique
donc voilà donc la première
interglaciaire va permettre à sapiens de
sortir mais la période glaciaire qui va
suivre est bien va briser leur élan et
ce n'est qu'à la deuxième sortie
d'afrique donc un nouvel épisode
interglaciaire ce n'est qu'à un nouvel
élan à partir de 80 mille ans et
ininterrompue depuis j'ai presque envie
de dire que sapiens va sortir
définitivement d'afrique donc s'hybrider
avec les néandertal qui sont toujours là
mais à partir de 43 milan en fait
néandertal va faire que régresser la
dire on voit bien d'ailleurs au niveau
du registre fossile dadis la
distribution de néandertal régresse
d'abord il disparaît donc du levant puis
il va disparaître d'europe de l'ouest et
puis il ya vingt à trente cinq mille ans
et bien il
il ya entre 35000 et 25 mille ans il
disparaît d'abord de france et puis
d'espagne et pouf
c'est la fin de néandertal complètement
remplacé par homo sapiens
et de l'autre côté et bien on a pas on
n'a pas un registre fossile aussi nette
de la disparition d'homo erectus mais
comme je voulais dit le dernier homo
erectus c'est un probablement il ya 80
mille ans en indonésie le homo
floresiensis donc qui se retrouvent qui
se trouvait par là c'est un ya cinquante
mille ans donc quand justement envoyé 45
mille ans quand homo sapiens arrive dans
la région donc il ya possiblement aussi
sapiens qui a botté le cul ses
congénères en asie évidemment il ya tout
le débat sur le leur at il botté le cul
volontairement ou non
ou est ce que c'est juste de la
concurrence écologique ou est ce qu'il
sait hybride est bon alors maintenant on
a des traces d'hybridation ça veut pas
dire que l'hybridation est la cause de
la disparition des autres espèces
mais on va discuter de ça dans le détail
vous en faites pas et donc à huy
rapidement j'avais cette j'avais cette
diapos que je ne savais pas trop où m
c'est pourquoi les liens pourquoi les
néandertaliens ce son état je voulais
parler de cette hypothèse fort
satisfaisante mais pas forcément la plus
pauvre forcément la plus consensuelle
qu'en fait les c'est la domestication
des chiens qui a donné un avantage aux
néo aux humains modernes
comparé aux néandertaliens donc sachant
que les premières traces de
domestication remonte à trente six mille
à 31000 ans avec ce chien là qui a été
retrouvé donc enterrée avec les honneurs
et à une petite dents de mammouth place
et intentionnellement dans sa bouche en
signe je suppose en signe de je sais pas
honorifique mais bref
et du coup le fait d'avoir des chiens
ont veillé accrue de 80% les chances de
chasse de chasse réussi chez homo
sapiens alors que néandertal lui se
serait retrouvée du coup sans équipement
on va dire mais bon c'est voilà c'est
une hypothèse un peu marginale mais je
la trouve séduisante parce que du coup
voilà quand on dit que le chien est le
meilleur ami de l'homme
ça donne envie de dire seulement d'homo
sapiens voilà donc est alors la trace
justement de cette première en fait la
trace de ces deux de ces deux vagues de
migration en fait elle se retrouve au
niveau génétique donc la deuxième vague
de migrants vous voyez la deuxième vague
de migration elle est là haut de vous
voyez la ligne rouge ici qu'ils
représentent
l'intervalle entre les deux vagues de
migrations donc la deuxième vague de
migration elle est là c'est celle qui a
donné lieu toutes les populations
modernes et la première vague de
migration en fait elle est là et vous
voyez en fait on la voit pas parce
qu'elle a disparu en fait toutes les
branches qui sont apparu de ce côté là
en fait elles se sont éteintes et ce qui
s'est passé pendant cet intervalle en
fait on pense déjà c'est comme je disais
il ya eu la concurrence de direct de
néandertal dans le vent qui a qui a pas
plu aux homo sapiens de l'époque
mais surtout ce qui a eu aussi c'est une
grosse grosse éruption volcanique qui
est qui et l'éruption volcanique du toba
en indonésie il ya soixante-quinze mille
ans et qui est qui a possiblement eu un
effet ce qu'on appelle un effet
bottleneck donc un effet goulets
d'étranglement sur les populations de
sapiens donc on estime d'après la
diversité génétique des sapiens moderne
en fait que la population de
la population du man est uniquement
moderne a chuté à moins de 75 mille
individus si je ne m'abuse non moins de
quinze mille individus bref quelques
milliers d'individus
donc qu'ils sont les ancêtres de tous
les humains modernes donc vous imaginez
que c'est on parle pas évidemment de la
population entière de l'humanité parce
qu'évidemment qu'ailleurs en afrique il
devait y avoir d'autres êtres humains
mais la population qui a donné les
ancêtres la population qui est les
ancêtres de tous les humains modernes
elle l a chuté drastiquement
voilà bon maintenant c'est un scénario
qui est discutée l'éruption du taux bas
comme un agent de comme un agent de
goulets d'étranglement de la diversité
humaine
c'est une hypothèse qui est très discuté
bien évidemment c'est une hypothèse qui
est tellement séduisante en fait que
c'est presque trop beau pour être vrai
donc évidemment il y a des arguments
pour il ya des arguments contre
donc petit résumé du voyage d'homo
sapiens et de ses rencontres et
notamment de ses rencontres amoureuses
au fur et à mesure de ses périgrinations
mondial donc homo sapiens comme je le
disais tous un format d'atomic mans
moderne on va dire qu'il démarre en
afrique il y a deux cent mille ans il ya
deux cent mille ans il est là il est en
afrique il est bien à la même époque vie
néandertal enfin apparaît d'ailleurs
néandertal en europe et donc l'homo
sapiens va sortir d'afrique
il y à 80 mille ans il va croiser
néandertal qui s'est répandue jusque
dans le levant il y à 90 il y à cent
mille ans et puis bah là ils vont faire
des bébés et aujourd'hui on sait qu' il
ya eu des bébés néandertal d'une part on
a des indices morphologiques parce qu'on
a des hybrides possible de néandertal et
de sapiens donc on a un hybride possible
dans une caverne dans une caverne
retrouvait en israël est qui et qui
présente donc d une mix de caractère de
sapiens et néandertal donc caractère de
sapiens qui est l'absence de boulay
supra orbitaire mais caractère de
néandertal qui est la forme plutôt au
blond de la boîte crânienne avec
justement ce front légèrement fuyant
donc
et là on a un autre hybride qui lui a un
pour les sursauts orbitaire bien
développés mais pour le coup un cerveau
bien globulaires donc on a des mix de
caractère en fait en israël et en italie
aussi on a des mix de cas on a ce cette
mâchoire qui est né lé néandertalienne
du point de vue de la robustesse
présumés des dents on va dire mais qui a
un petit menton voyez ce petit menton
l'a bien prononcé donc un petit menton
de sa place mais avec des grosses dents
de néandertal
donc on a des traces d'hybridation qui
sont physiques fossilisés et on a des
traces d'hybridation qui sont évidemment
dans les gènes des humains modernes et
notamment dans les gènes des populations
eurasiatique moderne
donc on retrouve des gènes qui sont
communs aux populations eurasiatique
moderne avec néandertal mais on ne
retrouve pas ces gènes chez les
populations africaines et ça ça veut
dire que il y a eu et bride à sion on y
au delà quand on est homo sapiens s'est
dispersée hors d'afrique au niveau du
levant justement au niveau du
moyen-orient donc il ya environ 2 à 4%
des gènes de néandertal moderne de
d'homo sapiens moderne 2 à 4% des gènes
d'homo sapiens moderne qui appartiennent
en fait à néandertal qui sont
directement hérité de néandertal donc
néandertal n'est pas complètement éteint
il est à 96 à 84 98 %
en réalité si on cumule tous les gènes
de néandertaliens qu'on retrouve chez
toutes les populations asiatiques
on atteint presque 20 pour cent du
génome de néandertal donc néandertal net
1 81% voilà ce qu'il faudrait dire en
réalité
donc voilà un résumé finalement des
échanges génétiques parce qu'évidemment
dans tout ça il faut aussi parler de
denisova parce que néandertal et enfin à
parler de d'hybridation ça se fait faut
évidemment parler denisot va alors je
vais aller un peu plus loin je vais
aller tout de suite à cette diapos l'a
donc néandertal néandertal et denisot va
en fait ils ont vécu plus ou moins dans
la même aire de répartition c'est-à-dire
europe de l'ouest slash sibérie et donc
ils ont fait des bébés aussi les nerfs
des néandertaliens les denisovans donc
donc vous voyez ici qu'il ya des
échanges
il ya aussi eu des échanges de gueule
gènes entre néandertaliens et denisova
et entre denisova et population
asiatique humaine donc c'est la
prochaine étape du voyage des êtres
humains donc les êtres humains pouf
envahissent l'asie il y à environ 70
milles ans durant la deuxième poussée
donc là on parle de la deuxième
migration celle qui a donné les
populations humaines modernes et encore
une fois ils ont fait l'amour avec les
denisot va c'est ce qui vous ai montré
ici donc des transferts de gènes qu'on
retrouve chez les denisovans fin des
transferts de gènes qu'on retrouve chez
les denisot va et chez les populations
asiatiques mais pas chez les populations
européennes ou africaines qui montre que
du coup le
les néandertal les humains et les
denisot va on fait des enfants aussi et
donc les denisot va on retrouve leurs
gènes comme je disais chez les
populations asiatiques moderne et
notamment on retrouve un gène qui
s'appelle et peu le mpp à s1 et eps 1
c'est un gène de résistance à l'hypoxie
donc c'est un gène qui permet en fait de
vivre à haute altitude là où l'oxygène
est raréfié et ce gène epas1 il est
présent chez les denisova et apparemment
il semblerait qu'il ait été hérités chez
les populations humaines modernes
enfin chez les populations humaines
modernes mais tibétaine une équipe
uniquement donc les tigres les tibétains
qui vivent à basse altitude enfin les
asiatiques qui vivent à basses latitudes
non pas ce gène mais les tibétains eux
l'ont enfin ont une version mutée du
gène qui leur permet d'avoir une
résistance à l'hypoxie et ça ça
viendrait des denisot va donc là je vous
montre ce que je vous montre ses seins
crâne supposé de denisova qui est
d'ailleurs intéressant parce qu'il a un
volume endocriniens 2800 centimètres
cubes ce qui est beaucoup plus que même
que le plus gros des des crânes de
néandertal et vous avez ici la seule
mandibules attester de denisova pourquoi
je dis que c'est la seule à tester parce
que c'est la seule mandibules de c'est
le seul fragments osseux de denisot
vient enfin le seul fragment crânien de
denisot vient sur lequel on a fait des
analyses génétiques qui ont permis de
confirmer que c'était du denisot va
parce que denisot va on connaît que les
gènes au final on a quelques fragments
osseux dont on a extrait l'adn on a vu
que cet adn étaient différents des gènes
de néandertal et l'homo sapiens mais qu'
il vivait à la même époque
donc on a déduit à partir de l'adn de
ces fragments osseux que denisot va
était une espèce différente mais au
final on n'a jamais trouvé de fossiles
descend de denisot va donc il ya ce
crâne qui est possiblement le crâne
danone iso vient mais on n'a pas encore
fait d'analysé génétique dessus et il ya
cette mandibules sur laquelle on a fait
des analyses génétiques parce que
justement il ya des dents et que les
dents conserve l'adn beaucoup mieux que
les eaux et là on a pu voir que
effectivement c'était bien une mandibule
denise ovale et qui ressemble beaucoup
d'ailleurs à une mandibule de néandertal
sous dit en passant donc siad ce qui est
intéressant aussi avec l'adaptation à la
vie en haute altitude c'est que on a
donc d'un côté les tibétains qui ont
acquis qui aurait acquis cette
adaptation à la vie en haute altitude
ans hybride ans avec les denisova mais
de l'autre côté du pacifique
on aurait les populations en dn qui elle
aurait évolué une adaptation à l'hypoxie
à partir d'autres gènes donc pas du tout
est pas un
mais un gène qui des gènes qui s'appelle
prk aaa et
nos2 a donc scellé des adaptations à
l'hypoxie très similaire mais à partir
de gènes différents donc adaptation
totalement convergente chez les
populations en dn et d'ailleurs il ya
débat sur est ce que le gène epas1
n'aurait pas muté de façon complètement
convergentes chez les tibétains
parce que le truc c'est que très
récemment et je remercie d'ailleurs mon
collègue fabien pour m'avoir indiqué
cette publication récemment en fait on a
découvert que ep à que le une version
très similaire du gène epas1 circule
chez les chiens adapté à la haute
altitude et là pour le coup il n'y a pas
de questions d'hybridation possible avec
denisot va
voilà donc il est possible aussi
d'évoluer une version très similaires
aux gènes e p as un des denisovians de
façon complètement indépendante et et
pourquoi et la question du coût se pose
est-ce que la version que les tibétains
on est vraiment hérité de denisova où
est-ce qu'ils l'ont acquise
indépendamment du coup mais voilà c'est
des histoires qui sont tout à fait
passionnante ces histoires de gênes et
on continue notre voyage donc il ya des
moments il ya un moment où homo sapiens
a dû rencontrer d'autres de ses cousins
donc notamment les cousins de là
de la grotte enfin de la caverne du cerf
rouge ou de la caverne auxerre comme on
l'appelle aussi qui vivait il ya treize
mille ans et qui sont une espèce humaine
qui n'a pas encore de nom mais qui a la
particularité d'avoir ces très grandes
arcades rue galles alors c'est pas des
parents trope c'est pas des parents
trope même s'ils ont effectivement ce
caractère qui ressemble tout simplement
parce que la boîte crânienne vous pouvez
voir le front et bien et bien droit il
n'ya pas de bourg les suces orbitaire
donc ils ressemblent à sapiens en fait
de ce point de vue là donc c'est juste
les joues qui ont l'air d'être sûr
développer chez ce peuple de la caverne
auxerre et on ne sait pas d'où ils
sortent on n'a pas dalanis génétique et
il ya très peu d'articles qui ont été
publiées à propos de ce peuple de la
caverne auxerre et donc on n'a aucune
idée de est ce qu'ils ont fait l'amour
avec ou pas et puis on a le les
populations insulaires donc le fameux
homo lui sonne n 6 et le fameux hobbit
dont clomot floridienne 6 qui a vécu
entre un million d'années cinquante
mille ans et donc homo floresiensis il
aurait et homo ludens il aurait évolué à
partir de population d'homo erectus
asiatiques qui se serait retrouvée
isolée sur sur des îles et ça c'est ça
c'est très intéressant comme phénomène
parce que encore une fois ça veut dire
que l'homo sapiens n'échappe à la fin
que homo n'échappe pas à la sélection
naturelle quand il atterrit sur une île
il est phénomène il est il subit les
mêmes phénomènes de nanisme insulaire
que toutes les autres espèces qui se
retrouve isolé sur les îles et archers
homo floresiensis vous avez peut-être
noté
la taille du cerveau qui est de 400
centimètres cubes donc homo floresiensis
il montre aussi ce que ce dont je vous
avais parlé avec les chevaux c'est qu'il
faut pas s'arrêter aux tendances
évolutives
on a on a vu qu'il y avait effectivement
une tendance évolutive à l'augmentation
de la taille du cerveau dans le genre
homo mais en fait c'est une tendance à
la diversification de la taille du
cerveau donc à la fin on a une diversité
de taille de cerveau est d'ailleurs fort
et parlé d' homo naledi aussi parce que
mona lady à la même époque alors entre
un million d'années cinquante mille ans
il a un cerveau de 406 400 à 500
centimètres cubes donc en fait le
cerveau il ne fait pas que augmenté en
taille
il se diversifie en taille dans la
lignée humaine et ça c'est beau et ça
c'est beau et c'est pas parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya 15 ans il n'y a
qu'une seule espèce qui survit qu'il
faut négliger pour autant les espèces
éteintes
alors l'être humain arrive du coup il ya
cinquante mille ans en australie et du
coup comme on a vu en australie je vous
rappelle le court qu'on a eue sur les
marsupiaux
il va avoir un tableau de chasse assez
remarquable puisqu'il va être
responsable de l'extinction de la
plupart de la mégafaune australienne et
puis il y a quinze mille ans enfin homo
sapiens traversent le détroit de
gibraltar détroit de béring à la faveur
d'une de la déglaciation en fait donc
c'est pas parce qu'il y avait de la
glace sur les détroit de béring que
l'uma est passé c'est parce que
justement il y avait des glaciations et
que du coup c'est pendant le petit
intervalle de temps où la glace n'a plus
recouvert le continent mais que l'eau
n'avait pas encore remontés c'est
pendant ce petit intervalle là en fait
que sapiens est passé donc c'était il ya
entre 13000 et 15 mille ans
et donc c'est le clad que vous voyez ici
donc on peut aussi daté par horloge
moléculaire et l'horloge moléculaire
confirme d'ailleurs que c'était entre
13000 et 15 mille ans donc les
populations asiatiques elles sont elles
sont elles sont là déjà dansé dans ses
parages l'a donc l'homme par exemple a
déjà atteint le japon il ya 6000 ans et
il a une culture aussi qui est très
proche de la culture qu'on retrouve
après en amérique du nord autour de
quatorze mille à dix mille ans et qui
s'appelle la culture clovis donc la
façon de tailler les outils s'appelle la
culture clovis et la culture qui en en
extrême orient à cette époque est assez
similaire à la culture clovis
donc on a de bonnes preuves à la fois
génétique et archéologiques que c'est
bien par le détroit de béring que
l'homme s'est dispersé en amérique du
nord puis en amérique du sud et que tout
ça est arrivé très rapidement parce qu
on a beaucoup de monde et couvre de plus
en plus finalement de traces humaines
qui datent même de vous voyez même de
quinze à quatorze mille ans donc je vais
pas aller jusqu'à dire que c'était
quasiment instantanée mais voilà entre
entre 15000 et entre 15000 et 13000 en
poupe le voyage l'a tout ça c'est
accomplir donc c'est un voyage qui a été
très rapide incroyablement rapide et
donc là ce que vous voyez c'est l'un des
plus anciens crâne humain d'amérique du
nord qui datent de 14 mille ans
justement est donc pareil à la mégafaune
va prendre cher dans sa phase quand
l'être humain va arriver en amérique du
nord alors ces années c'est une photo un
peu quelqu'un que j'ai pris en amérique
du nord mais je la trouvais tellement
parlante que je pouvais pas la rater que
je pouvais pas ne pas la mettre
c'est parce que la photo ait raté sinon
mais voilà c'est c'est une image qui
montre la mégafaune avant quinze mille
ans et la mégafaune après quinze mille
ans enfin après dix mille ans
du coup et vous voyez qu'il reste plus
rien il reste plus rien c'est de la
folie
donc là pour le coup l'amérique du nord
il ya le changement climatique qui va
jouer pas mal parce qu'évidemment
l'amérique du nord faut vous imaginer
qu'elle était gelé jusque là pendant la
glaciation
donc quand tout ça ça à décongeler il ya
eu des changements climatiques et
écologiques assez foudroyant il ya eu
des notamment des glaciers enfin des
lacs glaciaires qui ont fondu des lacs
qui faisait presque
un dixième de la surface du continent
qui est tout à été relâchés en l'espace
de quelques
de quelques jours nous contenu tout
c'est là qu'a été relâchés en l'espace
de quelques jours donc on a eu des
catastrophes monumentale des
catastrophes qui ont même changé qui ont
créé des mini-stages glaciaire locaux on
va dire tellement elle était gigantesque
d'entasser un phénomène fascinant le la
fin de l'ère glaciaire en amérique du
nord et qui a été très bien étudié
puisque c'est l'amérique du nord et
qu'ils ont les moyens mais voilà le il
ya un phénomène fascinant qui s'est
passé là-bas et et malgré tout ce qu'on
en sait et ben on n'est toujours pas
capable de dire si c'est l'homme ou pas
qui a qu'un qui a provoqué l'extinction
de tous ces animaux
mais voilà si en partant du principe que
c'est l'homme qui a causé l'extinction
de tous ah bah voilà les body quand donc
ce qui est intéressant c'est de
constater que déjà en afrique il ya très
peu de mégaphones qui s'est retrouvé
éteinte avec l'apparition de l'homme il
ya deux cent mille ans 200 milles à 60 à
160 mille ans donc l'apparition d'homo
sapiens ne coïncide pas avec un pic
d'extinction de même quant à caen
en europe l'apparition d'homo sapiens ne
coïncident pas non plus avec une grosse
extinction il ya que neuf espèces de la
mégafaune qui sont éteintes et encore
une fois en europe c'est pareil c'est la
fin de l'ère glaciaire les les glaciers
reculent la géographie change donc voilà
il ya des changements écologiques en
plus de l'arrivée de l'homme qui sont
qui ont joué un rôle donc mais voilà on
est sur des mais on est sur des régions
qui étaient peuplés par homo
neandertalensis ou homo sapiens alors
que quand on arrive en a donné 10 où il
y avait personne
là pour le coup enfin quand on arrive en
australie où il y avait personne n'a la
bam le bandit quand il arrive à 21 quand
on arrive en amérique du nord où il y
avait personne dames le body quand ils
t'ont ils montent à 33 et là où c'est la
catastrophe nationale c'est c'est
l'amérique du sud avec 50 50
et là pour le coup vous voyez les petits
indicateurs verts qui disent qu'il ya
des bonnes évidence pas des bonnes
preuves que c'est l'homme qui a causé
l'extinction là ils sont ils sont
complètement ouvert pour ce qu'il s'agit
de l'amérique donc donc eh ben voilà
l'homme l'homme qui cause des
extinctions c'est pas nouveau ça a rien
de nouveau
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il ya débat
sur qu'est ce qu'on doit appeler
l'anthropocène parce que l'homme qui
provoque des extinctions d'espèces c'est
c'est pas nouveau du tout et on peut
même voir d'ailleurs que les espèces ont
évolué pour résister à l'homme en
afrique puisque du coup les les
extinctions était déjà moindre en
afrique et du coup je réalise que j'ai
oublié de faire mon ma petite aparté sur
le débat n'est sapiens neanderthalensis
et sapiens sapiens donc si vous partez
du principe qu'il y a eu une bride à
sion entre sapiens et néandertal n 6 ça
veut dire que sapiens et néandertal
ensisa partys à partir et à la même
espèce donc que ce serait sapiens
neanderthalensis et sapiens sapiens mais
comme je les dis l'origine de néandertal
est tout sauf certaines et quoi qu'il
arrive néandertal enfin le problème si
on considère néandertal comme
appartenant à
à l'espèce sapiens ça veut dire que
leurs ancêtres en commun qui est homo
heidelbergensis ou homo erectus doit
aussi être appelée sapiens par extension
et là vous commencez à vous dire mais
alors ça veut dire que l'espèce homo
sapiens il faut la faire remonter à 1,8
million d'années
et là ça devient n'importe quoi parce
qu'ils n'ont rien à voir les homos et
enfin les homo erectus ils ressemblent à
des humains et ils marchent debout il
avait probablement une une démarche très
proche de la nôtre mais je veux dire
morphologiquement le crâne
morphologiquement le crâne il a rien à
voir avec celui d'un humain moderne donc
vouloir mettre homo erectus mêmes homo
heidelbergensis dans le genre ça pias
sous prétexte que néandertal et sapiens
était capable de s'hybrider un peu parce
que je rappelle qu'on a que 2 à 4% des
gènes donc c'est pas non plus on n'est
pas sur un phénomène de de mixage
de mixage intensifs on est sur des
rencontres courte mais intense j'ai
envie de dire donc voilà est-ce que ça
vaut le coup pour autant de [ __ ]
encore plus le bordel dans la taxonomie
en allant appelé sapiens des trucs qui
n'ont pas la morphologie de sapiens
moderne quoi et ça c'est ça c'est le
sait le coeur du problème j'ai envie de
dire c'est que si on appelle néandertal
sapiens neanderthalensis bah du coup on
doit avoir aussi à saint piat cette
dalle bergen cissé voire même un sapiens
erectus et voire même à sapiens ergaster
donc donc donc moi je j'aime mieux
rester sur une sachant qu'on est des
paléontologues
moi j'aime mieux rester sur une
définition purement morphologiques d'
homo neandertalensis homo
neandertalensis à des caractères qui se
distingue très facilement d'homo sapiens
donc je parle d' homo neandertalensis et
pas de homo sapiens neanderthalensis
voilà et je garde la définition purement
morphologiques parce que nous sommes
paléontologue et que c'est comme ça que
ça marche chez les paléontologues
si j'étais généticien je partirai
peut-être dans l'autre direction mais un
généticien on en a rien à cirer domeizel
berriane 6 voilà est d'ailleurs puisque
l'homme de denisova est aussi proche
parent de hanter ses sorts et de
néandertal denisot va est aussi un
sapiens par extension vous voyez le
problème
ça devient du grand n'importe quoi si on
se met à admettre que ça si on se met à
admettre qu'on doit appeler l'homme de
néandertal sapiens neanderthalensis ça
devient du grand n'importe quoi
donc voilà pour simplifier les choses
j'aime mieux parler de néandertal et de
sapiens séparément voilà et donc
dernière ligne droite
est ce que l'humain continue d'évoluer
la réponse est oui
donc on continue d'évoluer déjà on
continue à s'adapter aux maladies qui
nous tombe dessus chaque année
alors il ya beaucoup de maladies dont on
arrive à se débarrasser grâce à des
vaccins grâce à des traitements etc
oui mais alors quand on me dit ouais
mais l'humain il évolue plus parce que
on est on est protégé contre les
maladies grâce à la médecine moderne
j'ai envie de dire oui toi petit
occidental tué peut-être tu as peut-être
accès à une sécurité sociale qui te
fournit 2 qui te fournit des médicaments
gratuitement mais c'est pas le cas de
tout le monde
et d'ailleurs il ya même des pays où les
médicaments que tu peux te procurer très
facilement en europe n'existe pas du
tout et donc quand on regarde un peu
l'afrique et qu'on regarde notamment le
est bien là la malaria donc la malaria
c'est le paludisme est bas les pays
d'afrique ils n'ont pas accès à des
traitements quand contre la malaria
comme nous on en a et du coup il ya
encore une sélection naturelle très
forte pour des résistances à la malaria
et notamment une des formes de
résistance à la malaria c'est une
mutation qui causent l'anémié falciforme
donc ça c'est un exemple c'est un
exemple que vous retrouverez dans tous
les livres même au niveau lycéens
je veux dire à ce niveau là donc être
hétérozygotes pour la maladie génétique
qui causent l'anémié falciforme
c'est une forme de résistance à la
malaria et c'est bizarrement une
mutation qui est très prépondérante en
afrique dans les zones fortement
touchées par la malaria ski ski ce qui
n'est pas rien donc et voilà c'est tout
ça c'est comme je dis c'est le monde
entier n'a pas accès au confort
occidental donc donc oui l'évolution
elle continue la sélection naturelle
elle continue et l'adaptation maladie
elle continue j'ai presque envie de dire
hélas puisque puisque ça veut dire que
pour que sélection naturelle il y est il
faut que des gens meurent autrement ça
ne marche pas à part sur des maladies
qui castre comme les oreillons
éventuellement mais comme les oreillons
là pour le coup on a les vaccins et que
c'est un des vaccins les plus répandus
bâle a du coup là du coup vous pouvez
avoir sélection naturelle mais avec les
oreillons voilà vous pouvez avoir
sélection naturelle sans pour autant en
mourir mais bon voilà c'est beau ça
reste ça reste une maladie et être
castré ça reste rare est pas agréable du
tout voilà alors on s'adapte à
l'agriculture et alors là je vous
renvoie évidemment à toutes les vidéos
de la chaîne qui s'appelle le vortex où
ils ont parlé de l'adaptation des êtres
humains à l'agriculture et c'est
absolument prodigieux donc il faut aller
voir ses vidéos
elles sont très très enrichissante alors
là le le le point d' attaques qu'ils ont
dans le vortex c'est d'expliquer aux
gens qu en fait la pire chose qui soit
arrivée à l'humanité c'est probablement
l'agriculture là dessus j'ai tendance à
pas être d'accord je vois pourquoi ils
disent ça je comprends très bien
pourquoi ils ont choisi cet angle
d'attaqué mais à côté de ça si
l'agriculture c'était vraiment la pire
chose qui était arrivé à l'humanité les
ce serait pas aussi répandues que ça
veut dire ça ça n'aurait pas marché ça
aurait capoté et ça aurait mené nulle
part non l'agriculture a amené des
avantages qui compensait largement
l'agriculture a amené des avantages en
termes de succès reproductif qui ont
largement compenser les inconvénients en
termes de
d'un confort et de malnutrition et de
tout ça parce que l'agriculture c'est de
l'inconfort de la malnutrition et des
maladies des maladies qui vous sont
transmises justement par les animaux que
vous élevez notamment la peste par
exemple la peste la rougeole la variole
tout ça c'est ça vient des animaux en
face tout ça c'est directement dérivés
de l'élevage
parce que c'est le contact prolongé avec
les animaux qui nous amène ces choses là
avec des animaux ou avec les parasites
des animaux comme les puces la pesse la
peste et transmises par les puces donc
voilà donc l'agriculture on a là on a
ici donc les différents centres de
développement indépendants de
l'agriculture donc l'agriculture
l'agriculture telle qu'on la pratique en
europe elle est née dans le croissant
fertile mais il y avait aussi des
centres d'agriculture et d'élevage qui
se sont développés en afrique il ya des
se sont développées indépendamment en
chine en nouvelle guinée est évidemment
en amérique puisqu'on a appris à
cultiver le maïs les tomates le tabac
enfin le cacao
tout ça ça s'est développé
indépendamment aussi de donc on a
tendance à dire que le berceau de
l'agriculture c'est le croissant fertile
oui pour nous européens mais pas pour
pas pour la chine
pas pour l'afrique et pas pour la mairie
qui a des yeux il ya eu des
développements des centres de
développement de l'agriculture et de
l'élevage indépendant sur chaque
continent et même
même à l'intérieur de chaque continent
puisque vous voyez l'un d'eux aussi
développer l'agriculture de façon
parallèle à la chine donc
et curieusement dans les centres
agricoles et agricoles les plus les plus
intenses
et bien c'est aussi là qu'on va trouver
l'adaptation les adaptations à la
consommation de lait donc et à la
consommation de d'amidon donc pour pour
consommer de l'amidon ils font sécréter
beaucoup d'amis là dedans et ça c'est dû
à des mutations des mutations qu on
retrouve donc dans les grands centres
agricoles donc voilà dans la région dans
l'afrique de l'ouest
on retrouve ça on retrouve ça dans le
croissant fertile
donc ces deux régions est bon là c'est
plus lent que le croissant fertile mais
voilà dans les régions
du croissant fertile qui ne sont plus
tellement fertile et évidemment en
europe
apparemment l'amérique du nord ça n'a
pas été étudiée mais bon ça c'est une
autre question
donc évidemment comme je le disais
l'adaptation à l'élevage va de pair avec
l'adaptation à tout un tas de maladies
donc la rougeole qui a été transmise par
les vaches la turberculose qui a essayé
d'être transmis par les vaches la
variole qui haïssent et qui a été
transmise par les vaches les grippes qui
sont transmises donc par les oiseaux et
par les cochons est alors perçu 6 je ne
sais pas ce que c'est mais ça n'a pas
l'air sympa non plus mais voilà le est
ce que ce serait pas est ce que ce
serait pas la tuberculose à bannans la
tuberculose elle est là bref donc voilà
il ya toutes ces adaptations et tout ça
ça va avec des adaptations du cou à ces
maladies quand on se met à mettre à
faire de l'élevage ya commence à y avoir
pression pression de sélection sélection
naturelle les survivants qui s'adaptent
à ces maladies sont enfin les gens qui
survivent à ces maladies sont des gens
qui transmettent leur adaptation est
parmi les maladies du coup il y à la
peste la peste qui est transmise par les
rongeurs dérange enfin qui est transmise
par les puces des rongeurs et donc la
peste elle est née en 1300 et d en chine
et elle a remonté toute la
la zone de la route de la soie et allait
arriver en europe donc dans le milieu d
animer le 3 sont donc la grande peste
noire qui arrive en europe on a eu de
très très beaux on a une très très belle
documentation de la progression de la
peste noire qui nous montre très bien
d'où elle est venue et comment elle est
arrivée là et donc et cette peste noire
encore une fois c'est une conséquence
directe de l'adaptation
c'est une conséquence directe non
seulement de l'élevage mais aussi et
surtout de l'urbanisation
l'urbanisation donc qui rapproche les
gens et cette belle promiscuité et bien
les maladies les maladies infectieuses
s'en régalent et est donc encore une
fois il faut l'humain s'adapte à
l'urbanisation en s'adaptant non
seulement à la pollution mais aussi aux
maladies qui vont avec l'urbanisation et
alors il ya une idée qui a été proposé
récemment qu en fait l'une des
protections compte l'une des protections
génétique qu'on développe et les
européens suite à la peste noire ce je
rappelle qu'il ya quand même un tiers de
la population qui a crevé donc c'est
grosse sélection naturelle et bien
certaines de ces protections notamment
la fréquence de l'allèle d'un juge d'un
gène nommé ccr5 serait aussi enfin
serait en train d'être coopté on va dire
comme protection en fait pour contre le
sida
enfin contre le vih et alors ça c'est
une idée je trouve ça cool je trouve ça
cool lui mais pourquoi pas donc toujours
en adaptation contre les maladies
infectieuses
on voit aussi que les grands centres
d'urbanisation sont aussi ceux qui sont
le plus adapté à la tuberculose et à la
lèpre donc voilà les grands centres
historiques d'urbanisation et
d'agriculture
l'europe et la chine et l'inde sont
aussi ceux chez lesquels on retrouve le
plus de fréquences d'adaptation contre
la tuberculose et la lèpre et puis après
et est donc ça aussi ça explique
pourquoi finalement les pourquoi les les
européens ont transmis autant de
maladies en amérique du nord alors que
les en amérique alors que les américains
ont transmis très peu de maladies
ce que nous on leur a transmis toutes
les saloperies possibles et imaginables
à la lèpre la tuberculose
on leur a on aller choper la malaria en
afrique pour leur ramener en amérique et
et à côté de ça et puis évidemment la
variole et alors qu'un côté 202
l'amérique on a peut-être je dis bien
peut-être ramener la syphilis et c'est
tout syphilis qui est une maladie de
l'âme à la basse et une maladie
sexuellement transmissible de l'ama donc
je sais pas comment vous avez choper la
syphilis messieurs les conquistadors
mais c'est pas propre
c'est pas propre du tout bref donc voilà
pourquoi on a ramené si peu de maladies
d'amérique alors qu'on en a ramené
autant chez eux
eh ben c'est très probablement justement
à cause de l'urbanisation les européens
à cause de leurs arbres urbanisation ont
développé des tonnes et des tonnes de
maladies et de l'élevage ont développé
des tonnes de maladies infectieuses
contre lesquelles ils ont développé des
résistances par sélection naturelle à
force de crever jeunes est en mauvaise
santé
mais du coup les américains pendant ce
temps là les les amérindiens ne pas
développer de résistance contre ces
maladies là et comme il avait des
centres d'urbanisation et d'élevage
beaucoup moins grand beaucoup moins
développés eh bien il n'avait pas de
grosses maladies infectieuses à eux donc
ben donc du coup il c'est pour ça que
quand les européens sont arrivés en
amérique du sud
ben ça a été l'hécatombe pour les sud
américains qui n'étaient pas adaptés à
toutes ces maladies en fait ce qui
montre bien du coup que les européens
avaient développé des résistances que
les autres populations humaines n'avait
pas c'est là où je veux en venir
et alors le petit exemple sud-africain
atypique auquel je me dis même pas
duquel j'aime bien parler samedi c'est
la maladie de hooch tourner et alors du
coup vous allez voir ça ça marche ça va
parler aux français aussi
donc la maladie de ochun alors je
prononce pas ça comme il faut du tout ça
se prononcent pas comme ça où tu
retournes mais ça s'écrit ochun alors je
le prononce ou chun donc la maladie dit
shawn c'est une maladie que qui est très
prépondérante chez les afrikaners donc
chez les blancs sud-africains chez les
blancs sud africains d'origine
d'origine
hollandaise les afrikaners c'est ça
c'est des blancs sud africains d'origine
hollandaise parce que vous avez aussi
les blanches et africains d'origine
anglaise mais les blancs sud africains
d'origine anglaise n'ont pas une telle
prépondérance de la maladie donc la
maladie de hooch tourner
c'est une maladie en fait de la peau qui
se développe vers l'âge de 50 ans vers
l'âge de 40 50 ans et donc ça donne
cette ce que vous voyez là sur la main
des rougeurs et puis de la peau qui pèle
ce n'est pas une maladie grave c'est
juste des rougeurs la peau qui pèle et
une sensibilité accrue
et donc c'est une maladie qui s'est
transmise principalement parce qu'elles
s'expriment tard dans la vie du coup
après l'âge de la reproduction donc elle
ce serait ça se transmet comme une
traînée de poudre
parce qu'on réalise pas qu'on est malade
avant de s'être reproduit copieusement
voilà et puis de toute façon comme c'est
pas spécialement handicap enfin c'est
handicapant mais je veux dire c'est pas
c'est pas mortelle
bah du coup on s'en fout voilà surtout
les imaginez bien que les afrikaners à
l'époque de la colonisation les bourgs
comme on les appelait et c'était du
c'était dur à cuire à l'époque un
c'était pas des c'était pas du délicat à
se mettre de la nive et assure les mains
quoi donc
mais trêve de clichés donc et ça et
cette maladie de ochun on sait d'où elle
vient enfin depuis deux ans il ya des
recherches
conjointe par des généticiens des
médecins et des historiens qui ont fini
il ya deux ans par mené à la découverte
en fait dû j'ai envie de dire du
[ __ ] qui a ramené la maladie de
hooch monde en afrique du sud
et ce [ __ ] c'est françois régnier du
mini un français qui est né à lorient
donc un breton voilà merci les bretons
donc voilà tout ça c'est venu d'un
français qui s'appelle françois besnier
du mini key qui est parti donc c'était
un huguenot donc c'était un c
c'était un protestant qui a été qui
faisait partie des protestants qui ont
été persécutés à l'époque de louis xiv
enfin que louis xiv a révoqué l'édit de
nantes donc après après ça donc les
huguenots ont été persécutés loup 14 le
14 étaient déjà morts en 1747 mais voilà
les lits des lacets des persécutions
religieuses qui ont repris à cause de
louis xiv et de la révocation de l'édit
de nantes
donc les huguenots ont fui en hollande
les hollandais les hollandais qui avait
déjà fondé la colonie du cap voulait
faire grand fair voulait avoir des
vignes en afrique du sud parce que tu
peux pas faire grandir de vignes en
hollande on se pèle trop les meules donc
il voulait faire grandir des vignes en
afrique du sud dans la colonie du cap et
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont envoyé les
protestants français qui sont venus se
réfugier en hollande en afrique du sud
et ses français on les appelle les
huguenots et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez si vous
regardez l'équipe de rugby sud-africaine
vous avez des duplessis par exemple à
l'intérieur d'eux dans l'équipe de rugby
c'est pour ça que vous avez énormément
de noms français d'ailleurs de manière
générale parmi les afrikaners parce que
justement à cause des huguenots qui ont
été envoyés là bas et donc parmi ces
huguenots et bien il y avait ce français
ce breton françois régnier du mini qui
était atteint d'une maladie de la peau
et qui a ramené cette maladie dans cette
toute petite colonie qu'était le cap à
l'époque parce que faut s'imaginer que
le cap c'était juste voilà les les
fortifications du château
enfin de la forteresse des maisons
autour et quelques fermes et voilà
c'était parce que le cap à l'époque
c'était simplement un point de
ravitaillement et on voulait y faire
grandir du vin on avait besoin d'y faire
grandir des vignes pour éviter que les
marins attrape le scorbut
parce que le scorbut c est le manque de
vitamine c est le meilleur moyen
d'éviter un manque de vitamine c c'est
la choucroute et le pinard
donc voilà donc on envoie ses huguenots
là bas parmi lesquelles quelqu'un cette
personne atteinte de la maladie qui
deviendra la maladie de lucho et ben et
comme le pool génétique à l'époque était
très petit dans la colonie du cap comme
n'y avait pas beaucoup de monde et bas
il y a eu à ce qu'on appelle un fender
effect donc un effet fondateur un effet
deux fondateurs qui ressemble un peu
encore une fois comme un goulet
d'étranglement sauf qu'on n'a pas les
tremblements on a juste on ajuste les
gènes qui se répandent après en fait
c'est comme un goulet d'étranglement
mais avec seulement le deuxième effet
kiss cool quoi avec seulement les gènes
qui se répandent dans la population un
gène qui n'est pas une adaptation mais
qui n'est pas non plus comme je les dis
à un inconvénient à la reproduction
puisque comme je les dis cette maladie
ne se déclare qu'après carénage
relativement avancé donc eh ben voilà
comment voilà comment presque 20% des
afrikaners finissent par développer la
ballade i ii ou chun alors que cette
maladie est tellement rare dans les
autres pays du monde que finalement elle
avait même pas de nom avant voilà ça
c'est le sait le voilà c'est ça montre
que les humains il évolue et que c'était
cette évolution s'est pas forcément non
plus de l'adaptation d'ailleurs vous
pouvez évoluer vous pouvez voir des
jeunes se répandre simplement parce
qu'ils ont une valeur sélective neutre
c'est ce qu'on appelle la sélection
neutre justement donc et la maladie de
ochun est en est un pov un parfait
exemple
donc voila et de manière générale de
manière générale j'ai envie de conclure
là dessus quand on vous pose la question
est ce que l'espèce humaine est encore
en train d'évoluer
le meilleur moyen de répondre c'est de
vous et de vous demander mais pourquoi
elle évoluerait plus l'espèce humaine
comment qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
pour pour que l'espèce humaine arrête
d'évoluer et ça vous pouvez vous poser
la question qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire pour que l'espèce humaine arrête
d'évoluer parce que l'évolution c'est
descendance avec modifications avec plus
ou moins de sélection naturelle après
donc si vous voulez arrêter la sélection
naturelle
vous allez il va falloir que tout le
monde se mette à mourir de façon
totalement aléatoire ou que les gens
arrêtent de mourir tout court l'un comme
l'autre est complètement impossible et
le deuxième est de toute façon même si
vous arrivez à arrêter la sélection
naturelle
je vous renvoie la maladie duch lourde
il reste encore l'évolution neutre il
reste encore la dérive génétique il
reste encore des mécanismes d'évolution
qui ne sont pas la sélection naturelle
donc ce qu'il vous faut arrêter c'est
pas la sélection naturelle
c'est la descendance avec modification
est ça le seul moyen d'arrêter la
descendance avec modification c'est de
passer au clonage ou d'arrêter de se
reproduire
voilà donc si vous voulez arrêter
l'évolution pour arrêter de se
reproduire il faut commencer à faire du
clonage et quand je dis du clonage c'est
que tout le monde le monde entier se
reproduit uniquement par clonage
et ce sans la moindre erreur génétique
donc il faut que les copies soit
absolument parfaite et et à ça j'ai
envie de dire bon courage donc l'espèce
humaine évolue-t-elle la réponse est
bien sûr que oui
le simple fait de n'être fait déjà de
vous un succès évolutif
le simple fait de vous reproduire fait
évoluer l'espèce donc voilà le vous êtes
un succès évolutif et si vous avez des
enfants vous êtes encore plus un succès
évolutif donc voilà je voulais conclure
sur cette idée là oui l'espèce humaine
évolue parce qu'il est impossible que
l'espèce humaine n'évolue pas merci à
tous et je vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine où nous parlerons des
mammifères sud américain
ciao